good morning everybody and welcome to
the mids development control B my name's
Kathy gri and I'm the chairman today I
know we're all in very difficult times
at the moment and um we will have had uh
a holiday break and I hope that was
successful for many of you um moving
forward we can continue with our
meetings so welcome to the development
control B May first of will remind you
some domestic arrangements please ensure
that microphones are muted when you're
not speaking that you do not interrupt
the other speaker members are not
reminded not to use the messaging chat
function during the meeting unless it is
to report a pecuniary or non-pecuniary
interest or to notify the chair that you
wish to make a proposal members are
reminded they should not have
alternative communication lines open and
that if you contacted by a third party
during the application you should bring
this to the legal advisor's
attention that if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to
leave Additionally you will be invited
to speak and ask questions by the chair
of the meeting please await your turn
we'll not be using the hands up function
except for Declarations of Interest site
visit Declarations of lobing and
questions for clarity we will be using
the electronic voting for this meeting
if you're experiencing poor connection
issues in the first instance please turn
off your camera if this does not work
please turn off the incoming video
please these options are under the three
dots on the main information bar I would
like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential exempt items if
you make a representation to the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to being recorded by
entering this meeting as a speaker and
you're also consented to being recorded
by the council and the possible use of
those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training
purposes the council members of the
public and press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully
excluded so I'll give introductions
first please we have Ian dpre the legal
advisor Robert carmichel our governance
officer Brun ctis the case officer the
area planning manager John pman G and we
have the ward members councelor Andrew
Stringer and councelor John
mat so can I move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and
substitutions thank you chair so this
morning we have apologies from councelor
gold and we also have councelor mayor
substituting for councelor gold this
morning thank you for
that do you wish to take a roll call or
uh no I've got everyone in modg now I
believe apart from councelor Stringer
but I believe that we're still sorting
that out right that's find by me and
will he be able to still listen to the
proceedings as we're going forward
absolutely chair absolutely I just to
know councelor Stringer does have his
hand up sorry yes councelor
Stringer sorry chair I was I I am in
modern. goov uh have been some minutes
and I was I was ahead of trying to
declare an
interest we like you to be
ahead to re to receive any Declarations
of pecuniary and non-pecuniary
by members so councelor Stringer yeah um
item what number is it uh Item B uh my
uh in-laws live in Union Road uh one
house okay and are close to this site
thank you very
much any other declarations no thank you
very
much Declarations of lobbying well I've
certainly had lobbying um on on the
first two applications so um I think
that probably is all of us um except for
possibly
counselor may or may not have done
because he's our substitute I've
received no lobbying check thank you for
that confirmation councelor War boys did
you get any
lobbying sorry no no thank you councelor
War booys just confirming that thank you
very much right thank you very much um
and they were presumably on the first
and second applications can I confirm
that
please councelor Norris
yeah councelor humre yes sorry yes uh
can I just mention I was only lobbied on
the first item 7A thank you very much
for that anyone else wish to make an
alternative declaration there uh yeah
councelor melon here yes same as Mike um
just item 7A right thank you very much I
had a letter regarding the second
application okay so we now move on to
Declarations of personal site visits
please any
declarations councelor
hrees mad Madam shair I live uh close to
the Union Road application so I know
that area well so I have seen it thank
you very
much so we now move on to confirmation
of the
minutes and it's points regarding
accuracy of the minutes and these were
the minutes of the 25th of
November councelor
Stringer thank you chair um yeah
obviously it's difficult with the
passage of time but with the help of
video uh I I failed to it for it to read
accurately that in between
3023 and
3024 could we possibly insert the words
a vote was not
taken uh because there was a passage of
time of some 15 minutes between those
two points and it makes it sound as if
on legal advice immediately the uh the
proposal was withdrawn it wasn't we did
debate for some time uh the merits of
that uh and and we didn't take a vote
and I then withdrew so that if I'm happy
for that thank you chair very happy
thank you chair yeah good and um Robert
can you insert that comment please pleas
yes chair councelor
melon um yeah thank you chair it's a
very it's on the same page in the minute
um uh it touches on point
3022 and then
30.25 when um councelor Humphrey's
proposed that we defer the application
to seek legal advice um uh Vince Pierce
made the suggestion that um that legal
advice would be shared with members and
that was taken up by Ian de pre and that
doesn't seem to have been captured in
the minutes there and neither have we
seen the brief well that well that will
only be shared um when it comes through
into when it's represented again in a
proceed
form well I'm just um in terms of
accuracy of the minutes that's what we
voted on we voted on the basis that we
would be shown the advice um and that is
not reflected in the minutes pre can you
just comment on that for us please
because that's my understanding of where
we are on it and I hear what councelor
melon is
saying in in you're
muted I'm not can I be heard now sorry
my phone yes that's better thank you yes
well just say Cel has been briefed to
advise the council I can confirm that
has been done um I I'm afraid I would
have to remind myself of the recording
to be I'm sorry I I not not to be more
direct but this is quite important we
get it right there was certainly there
was some discussion I don't think I
mean yeah I think there was discussion
of the fact that me Members needed to be
um happy with what was going on and with
the form and content of the advice I'm
really not sure at this point how
precise it
was um can I suggest that we defer to um
signing off the minutes until we get
clarity on that and bring them back at a
later date I think that would be best
madam chairman yes yeah thank for that
sorry I can't be more clear but I want I
this is obviously I me councel melon's
raised the point it's important that we
um yeah yeah so if we can leave the
minutes and bring them back at the next
meeting and have Clarity on that is that
all right with you councelor melon uh
yeah I mean I did um you know stay up
late last night listening to it and I
think it is fairly clear if one listen
all right we'll we'll we'll have to move
on and and get the legal um officer to
agree with what you're saying and thank
you for your input okay so we'll we'll
hold that that one till the next meeting
if we may thank
you um any further other other further
comments on the minutes
please now Andrew can you take your hand
down
[Music]
please um we now have C sorry to
interrupt we now have councelor Casten
um in um can you um advise we haven't
started a report or anything can we um
have councelor Caston in now
please chair sorry Mr if he wants you go
first Mr car Michel I'll add I'll add if
I need to thank you Mr pre so if I could
just ask just for the um as for the
normal proceedings if councelor Carson
could just um um go through the
formalities of if he's got any
declarations to make before we begin any
um items then that will be absolutely
fine for the proceedings
today councelor Casten are you with us
in you're happy with that if we go
through quite happy with that thank you
madam
[Music]
chair good morning councelor Casten and
I hope everything's resolved
satisfactorily at the moment for you um
can I just run through a few quick
things have you had any um pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interests in the cases
we're only doing the first two I must
add turn your mic up we can't hear
you take it you're
muted can you put it in um you can't
unmute your um computer oh
dear um can we put that in the chat for
the moment until um some it res
resolutions in would that be
acceptable if I ask the questions and
get um councelor kaston to put something
in the chat until until he gets that
unmuted yes as long as we know that
councelor Caston is is can hear what's
being said I mean I suppose it just
becomes a problem if he wants to speak
and can't be heard that you can hear can
you put your fingers up yeah so
councelor Kasten in the chat can you
please advise if you have any
Declarations of peun or non pecary
interest can you um offer any
Declarations of
lobbying and any Declarations of
personal site minute visits if you can
put that in the chat room while Mandy
tries to help you get um your sound up
and so long as you can continue to hear
us so I'll leave you to do that if you
can
[Music]
just right so can we ask um Mandy to
assist counselor Caston if he goes out
and comes back in again um and um Robert
shall we just wait a few minut minutes
while that
happens yes chair if we just wait um see
if that works in the first you want to
stop stop the recording for the moment
while that
happens yep so if Mandy if we could just
go to a very
quick
thank you very much everybody for your
patience um sorry about that we had some
technical difficulties so we now move on
to the agenda to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition
scheme thank you chair so just to
confirm there are no valid petitions
however I would just like to note that a
petition was received um regarding
before the festive period regarding um
item 7A which was assessed but was found
to be invalid so it's just for noting um
at that point but there are no valid
petitions before this morning thank you
chair thank you for that um so moving on
to the schedule of planning applications
we will be looking at them in the order
that they appear in the um papers um
which is um the first one 7A and 7B and
John pman G would you like to advise us
regarding 7 C and 7D which have been
withdrawn please thank
you yes so in respect of simply put they
have been withdrawn by the uh agent and
applicant uh so 7c and 7D are both uh
removed as planning applications and are
not therefore able to be determined by
us at any level um there's no right to
appeal the applicant has simply just
withdrawn them so they are taken off the
uh the schedule of planning applications
so we don't need to do anything further
and there's no further actions in
respect of those items thank you for
that uh John that's very helpful so we
now move on to the cast Hill Farm thoron
DC
20252 and the case officer Braun Curtis
will now introduce this application to
the committee thank you Brun over to you
good morning chair members thank you
Happy New Year everyone um I'll share
screen so that you can see the
presentation and I will start by taking
you through some verbal
updates bear with me just a
second
can I just get confirmation that that's
coming through okay can you see this
PowerPoint yeah that's fine thanks great
thank you okay so just starting with
verbal
updates um just to confirm that we have
a call-in request to the Secretary of
State on this
application um the only impact that that
has on members um decision making today
is that if the the vote is for a
resolution to Grant planning
permission we can um pass the resolution
but we are not able to issue a decision
until the Secretary of State have
considered um whether they want to call
it in it doesn't affect the
recommendation as it stands before you
and it won't affect decision- making if
the resolution is to go with officer
recommendation or or a version thereof
and refuse planning permission can you
just clarify for the public what the
recommendation is at the moment please
the recommendation is refuse planning
permission um the reason being on basis
of Oda which I'll go through in a little
bit more information in a moment um
there's also been um some information
that has come round from stradbrook and
thoron Parish
councils um regarding a traffic
assessment that they have done
independently and the challenge that
they've made to the traffic information
that's been submitted with the
application and commented on by suffer
County Council that
information um came in in response to
the re consultation exercise following
the change of the proposal and has been
available publicly and on our our
internal system for some weeks now but
it wasn't circulated as part of your
paper so it's just a point of clarity
that that has been available to members
for some time but you haven't got a copy
within your bundle the um the
information just to summarize because I
realized there's been a lot of
information um the parish councils have
collaborated to undertake their own
traffic modeling exercise and they
dispute the exercise that's been done by
the applicant and their their highways
consultant um in particular they draw
attention to the um expectation for a
far greater volume of movements as a
result of the proposed development and
some um alleged inaccuracies in the
information that's been
submitted I should however remind you
that suffer County Council have accepted
the information that's been submitted
and have given us their advice on that
basis without without querying the
content the methodology Etc so the
advice that um we're giving to you is on
the basis of that technical response
from the County
Council um another verbal update that I
have is on the status of the thoron
neighborhood plan it hasn't moved onto
the next stage from when I first wrote
the report so it's still just at that
post examination pre-referendum
stage and um there is also I've been
asked to include the crash map in the
presentation by chair so that will be
featuring and I will explain that when
we get to that point in the
presentation um and there is also a
point of clarity on the flood risk issue
it doesn't change the recommendation but
there is um I should point out that
there is a very small portion of the
access track leading from the highway to
the main part of the development site
that is affected by flood zones two and
three it's a it's a part of the site
that is already surfaced with imp
permeable um surface and that's not
going to change so the area in the
surfacing is not going to change as a
result of this development so it doesn't
have a material impact in terms of
drainage and flood risk but it's not
something that I have given um the
detail of in the report I've just given
a summary of the General flood risk in
the report so I hope that's clear I'll
take you through the slides now the
proposal is at Castle Hill
thoron um it's actually located in the
countryside between the Villages of Thon
and I um the road that you can see
running centrally in this view is the
road that goes between I and deham um
the application site is the hatched area
in the center of your screen there to
the left of that you can see Castle Hill
Farm the existing operation the existing
three sheds and The
Farmhouse and to the north you can see
the Covent former Huntington Life
Sciences Research Center
facility this shows that same sort of
image but on an ordinance base so that
you get a better understanding of where
the villages are and where the road
is and a slightly wider view
again
and this is showing in relation to the
County's hgv lorri root Network so the
application site is marked with a star
and you've got the main highways in Red
so you can see the a140 and the
a143 and then you have um the local
distributor roads suitable for
hgvs shown in the other
colors this um view shows the
application site with the pin in yellow
at the bottom and it's also got some of
um the other operations that are in the
area that form part of the supply chain
of um poultry meat production in the
area including um probably most relevant
is the crown processing plant at I which
is in the center
there this is a very similar map but
shows some other
um operating sites within this part of
the district so you've got Crown um
pinned red just below the
a140 sign but to the right of that
you've got a series of other um
operations intensive operations that um
are all related to the supply chain of
of this sort of agricultural undertaking
which just give you some context in
terms of the cumulative impact is issues
excuse me so I also need to make it
clear that this proposal has changed
from being a four shed proposal to a
three shed proposal that was done
partway through the application process
in order to try and address some of the
concerns that were raised so there may
be some elements that look as though
it's still four sheds um but I can
confirm the proposal is for three
Broiler units so that's intensive
livestock um operation broilers being
chickens reared for meat
production so this slide shows you the
site layout with the access coming
through the existing Castle Hill Farm
site The Proposal involves the
demolition of the existing three poultry
houses and then leading to the main part
of the site which is just south of the
Covent
complex and it shows you the layout of
the of the sheds and some some ancillary
Works sheds and silos parking areas Etc
these plans just give you an idea of the
shed
layout and
elevations and the ancillary
buildings
here and then photograph so this is an
aerial view which is a little bit more
updated showing the Cent site to the
north and if I can get my
cursor I can show you that the proposed
sheds are in this part of the site
here and then photographs around the
site so what you can see in this view is
the
um the western edge of the main part of
the site where the sheds are to go and
you can see the Covent site just beyond
the hedges in the background and then
we'll we'll turn this view turns around
to the
east so you can see the Covent site
Beyond the hedged boundary and trees
boundary in the
background and turning around further
towards the
east and then looking back towards the
existing
sheds which are to be
demolished you can just see The
Farmhouse there in the far
background uh this is an image taken
from Google Street View I apologize my
access image was awful so I had to to
take this one but that gives you the um
view of the existing site from the
road and this is the crash map that um
stradbrook and thoron Parish councils
have submitted with some information
relating to incidents in the
area that's where we're take us back to
an aerial
view so the proposal as I say is for an
intensive livestock operation three
sheds um there's been significant local
interest and objection particular issues
relate to impacts on residential
immunity arising from the operation in
terms of odor and most notably highways
um impacts um because of the routing
between this site and the crown chicken
processing site of ey lorries would be
rooted through thoron Village or through
it town center and um there is already a
significant amount of traffic both of
those directions and the residents of
those communities are already impacted
and have concerns about the additional
impact in terms of the highways impact
highways suff County Council highways
have been consulted on the application
and have considered the detail of the
proposal and the modeling information
that's been submitted and they are
advising that the impact is not at a
level that would be severe which is the
test in the mppf that we're required to
apply to the application and so they are
not recommending
refusal um in terms
of the Oda that is the other significant
issue and we have had lengthy
discussions between the environment
agency your senior environmental health
officer um and the applicant to to try
to um see if there are any workable
solutions to the proposal but you will
note from the consultation response that
even with the reduced thre shed proposal
the impact of odor generated from the
site is at a level that is not
considered to be acceptable um and that
is on the basis of the advice of The
Institute of air quality management and
um the guidance for planning
applications and the resultant
recommendation on basis of odor is that
that that would be um an impact that
would be significant enough to Warrant
refusal of the
application my report also picks up a
number of the other issues that have
been raised by the local community and
other material planning considerations
so there are issues relating to
biodiversity Heritage
impacts
um landscape impact visual immunity
including night skies
immunity um the flood risk and draining
issues and um and the economic benefit
of um agricultural development in the
district so I won't rehearse the whole
of the report because you've had a
chance to read it but I will just um
summarize by saying that the um outcome
is that the odor impact is Is Still
Remains even with a reduction in sheds
at a level that's unacceptable to your
offices and the recommendation is to
refuse planning permission thank you
chair um thank you before I just go to
um questions for the planning officer um
just to advise members that um you've
all read the report and thoron oold
Southold I stradbrook and denim Parish
councils all object this and I am
allowing obviously thoron will have
their three minutes but I have allowed I
um to also make a representation so if
you have any questions that might be
relevant you might need to note that um
so members do you have questions for the
planning officer please councelor
Norris
so yes thank you um on the point of
clarity on page
159 comments from the council's external
funding officer paragraph e second line
he only refers to two new
sheds and on pages 181 and
182 which are the floor plans and the
elevations they also only appear to show
two buildings could the officer just
clarify there was mention of the number
of sheds being reduced from four to
three but the papers in the pack seem to
only indicate
too thank you thank you thank you counc
noris yes I can confirm that the
proposal has been reduced from four
sheds to three
sheds so this view shows the areial of
three sheds and how they would how they
would be laid out and that is to replace
the existing three sheds that are at
Castle Hill Farm but I think councilor
Norris's question says that it was
referring to two was that a slip up of
the pen or
something that may well have been a typo
on my part or on the part of the
Consulting officer yeah I apologize for
that thank you for that councilor Nies
that satisfactory response uh well yeah
could I just ask are then the floor
plans and elevations shown on pages 181
and 182 are they only indicative then
because they only seem to indicate two
buildings they are handed so they are
identical for all buildings so rather
than us have duplicate of the same plan
they relate to all
buildings okay thank you thank you that
clarifies it for us thank you very much
councelor any further questions for the
officer councelor
Stringer yeah thank thank you chair um
just I've got several questions and I
I'll try and be as brief as I possibly
can uh you you you mentioned that the
traffic concerns were
regarding accessing the processing unit
but from the information certainly that
I have from the various spreadsheets
I've seen the majority of hgv movements
will be from feed and waste do we
actually know one where the feed is
coming from and where the waste is going
to
thank you councelor Stringer yeah I
focused on the um processing plant at
eye because that is a definite and um
the routing um from the site to to that
processing plant is going to definitely
need to go through through thornden and
I which is where the where a lot of the
concerns are um the other elements of
the operation are not yet fixed um but
there but the issues of waste and other
movements related to the operation have
been discussed and we have got
information in the traffic assessment on
that basis and we have been given
information on what's likely um we've
also considered um you'll note that this
application is an eia um that's because
when we scoped The Proposal we
considered the traffic impact in context
with other operations in this part of
the district to be such that it needed
to be considered as an eia application
because of that potential cumulative
impact so we have
considered um the traffic movements to
and from throughout the cycle of the
operation um and it does include um a
consideration of waste as well as things
like employees and litter and um other
resources that may be needed such as G
or um bedding or water um as well as
animal delivery and
collection yeah so so sorry can I come
back so so so do we know where the waste
is going to it's a considerable amount
uh you know and and the other concern
you mentioned the traffic routing
through thoron thoron has a weight
restriction through it so Thornton
cannot be part of the traffic rout
roting of
this that's right I understand that
weight restriction doesn't is not 24
hours though and the time of day that
the hgv movements are for a lot of the
operation would be outside of the
restrictive hours um to go back to your
question about waste we have had a
conversation with the applicant because
it's not certain they don't have a
definitive end user for Waste actually
agreed but what they have done is
explored the options and the options
include a site at um fford for um waste
processing as well as one at and I may
need the agent to confirm this when he
has an opportunity to speak um in
Norfolk South Norfolk somewhere I can't
remember the name of the location but we
don't have a definitive end user for
waste because that's not yet been
resolved by the
operator um councelor Stringer can I
just jump jump in there um to ask a
question following on from what you're
doing there is that um we obviously have
the debate to go forward and I
understand that um and we have the
recommendation which is refusal but if
the applicant goes to appeal we need to
have something in place that um makes
your point that you've raised there
clearer than just we've had a discussion
about it so I just thought I'd flag that
up would that be reasonable um Braun and
I'm asking you that question ahead of
further questions that I'm sure
counselor Stringer
has yes absolutely and I'm just having a
reread of my report I in terms of waste
I'm speaking about waste processing from
the operation has not yet been
determined it is likely that dead birds
will go to the cranswick site that's the
site of I litter waste to thatford
biomass Power Station waste water will
also be removed from the site by
contractor yet to be determined so we we
have some Pro objections for Waste
movements and waste operation we have
some information but we don't have um
all of the uh end users detailed in The
Proposal right so councelor Stringer
thank you for your question but I think
we can perhaps flesh that out when we
have the debate further are you
comfortable with that uh yeah yeah thank
you chair that that gets us someway some
way down that road just can I just have
one one more Point yes yes yes please
yeah one more Point thank you um you
mentioned that the processing plant is a
definite C can we then ask can I then
ask why is this not an
application by the definite end
user because that that seems to be
really difficult to get a hook on this
if it's not from uh cranswick itself uh
it it cranswick themselves say that they
control all areas of Supply so I'm
wondering why this is not a cranswick
planning application and other areas of
land in the area that they own I.E the
processing plant can't then be
conditioned as as as part of this
because it's not a cranck application
one other point and it is my final Point
can you clarify because our community's
officer is saying that this is to this
should be supported because of the that
somehow that cranswick may may fall into
difficulty in their supply chain if we
don't approve this uh can you tell me
how much of a percentage of the total
chickens needed for cranswick this site
will achieve thank
you thank you councelor Stringer um so
the first to answer the first question
um cranswick are not the operator of
this site so so that's why this
application is being made by um by
another party um which is a reasonable
and valid valid thing to do there is a
Market within the supply chain there are
a number of operators within our
district the majority of whom are not
cranswick SLC Crown um they are smaller
operators who have perhaps Diversified
from from other types of agricultural
operation um so that's that's not
dissimilar to what's happening here but
there is an opportunity presented by
cranswick for such operators so in terms
of the agricultural economy for our
district um this is a significant
contributor uh the question that you've
asked about the percent I will need to
research and come back to you I don't
have that information to hand it might
be something that the agent can more
readily answer but I will I will need to
try and go away and find that out for
you
please thank you very much for that
that's reasonable um obviously we don't
want to debate but we just want Clarity
which is um all very V valid points
thank you for that councelor Stringer I
have councelor melon and then councelor
War booys um these are questions for the
officer please councelor melon uh yes
thank you chair um a couple of brief
questions one is on Slide Five which is
the um County Council Lorry Roots um I
just want if the officer could just
explain the the significance of the blue
and the green and what those those roots
mean and then um the other thing is just
um we saw the crash map um very very
briefly it w it be possible to have a a
slightly longer look at that because
it's not in the
papers
thank you councel melon yes of course
let me just take you to those slides if
I can remember where they are in my
presentation so that's the crash
map this has been supplied by stradbrook
and thoron Parish
councils so can you just confirm the the
red
um the red way marks are
they um what significance of red or
yellow just to sort of clarify by
that I am going to assume that red and
um Amber are on the scale of severity
that is marked in that box but I will
need to this is not something that's
been SED by myself so I'll need yeah
please John may I come in on that so
there are three um essential um severity
and actually they are actually listed
there which is fatal serious and slight
uh amber I believe if I remember rightly
when I did it was obviously slight
serious is the red and black if there
was any black there isn't in this case
would be fatal so that is the uh and
there is a definition for each one of
those in in in the the context of that
particular
website
yeah thank you John let me just take you
back to the slide with the Lor
routing
sorry
it's yeah that's the one okay right be
me just a
second
so there must be some sort of key that
tells us what blue roots and green roots
are but um I'm not seeing it yeah and
I'm just going to confirm that for you
I'm just going to make sure I give you
the right information both me just a
second sure
so um the red route is a strategic Lorry
route um and the key says that all
movements Crossing suffk should use
these with those starting or ending the
county using them in preference to local
Lorry routs the blue ones are called
Zone distributor routs roads within a
Zone serving as a route directly to a
location or as a route to local access
routes which are green so the green are
local access routes weight restrictions
on a designated laer roots are shown
yellow
dotted and weight restrictions all 7.5
tons except we shown are shown solid
yellow so just to followup question this
is my last one um then clearly this site
is not on a green
route uh there is part of the green that
goes down to the a
1120 um on that road on the B10
77 and the b1077 is is green where it
meets the 140 up at the skull end but
the highway as it passes the site is not
a l route no yeah okay thank
you yeah I'm sorry I'm afraid you're on
mute trying to be clever is there anyone
else with hands up because I can see old
hands up that might be
there no yes Madam chair um councel
humre oh yes councelor humre sorry I
can't see um them coming through yes
your your question please thank you my
question is on the uh validity of the
crash map that you showed us because
I've looked at the crash map uh online
in fact I'm looking at it right now and
the only uh crash S I can see is on the
ey road which is serious nothing on CLE
Hill can you just go back to the slide
confirm that it's the same data
please thank you Council hre yes I'll
take you back to that um I should
clarify that this has come from Str and
thoron Parish councils we only got it
yesterday yeah sorry Monday
so it might be a slight point of order
supposing the fact that we've got to be
careful on the data we're shown because
that doesn't reflect the crash map.
co.uk that only shows one instant which
is the red one on ey Road can I come in
on that please chairman yes yes um I I'm
I'm not out to doubt anyone's data here
but ultimately what you have to do when
you go into this website you have to
identify the years that you wish to look
at it starts when you go into it for the
Last 5 Years obviously on this one
they've identified the last 21 years
which I think is the maximum time that
it allows you to identify um so any of
those uh dots the the yellow and red as
shown could be uh five years old could
be 20 years old or could be yesterday um
I don't think there's anything in the
last year actually um but there that's
not uploaded so I I don't know which
version you're looking at counselor in
respect of how the data you selected
exactly the same as you but I'm looking
back five years and the problem is
looking back 21 years it flaws the
evidence slightly um the world was
different 21 years ago um and again as
you said if we look at the last year I
don't think there are any uh no the 2019
would I think there's always a year
delay before the information is uploaded
so the last year won't be on there uh
until next year sometime um but I'm not
sure about that because obviously this
is an external uh source of information
uh and obviously when they upload an
update is up to them but obviously what
this is showing before us is 21 years
worth of data so again I don't without
selecting the individual uh entries we
don't know how old those individual
entries are uh obviously if you're
looking at a version that's only for the
last five years there will be less I
would suspect uh uh indicators on there
um but what judgment and weight you give
that is is obviously up to members yeah
that that's the reason I was asking the
question because I think it is important
that um you know yeah councelor I think
you've asked the question let's use that
in debate when we get forward cool and
and any further points on this issue I
can see councelor strings put his hand
up again but I think we'll use that in
debate we're just looking at Clarity
here so can you put your hands down if
you've um finished questioning and who
else has a question I can't
see anyone else uh there's me is me coun
uh chair Madam chair boys yeah okay I I
just can't see who's questioning
yeah thank you uh well I've got two
questions really but the first one is
when we're talking about odor we're
actually referring to air pollution in
in um in particular ammonia and it's uh
effect on the health of uh the
surrounding
inhabitants so what's your question then
please the question is I just want to
clarify that it's not just a case of a
bat smell it is in fact air pollution
which is dat which is BR can you whether
that is the point yes thank you
councelor War boys yes you're right
there are a number of um emissions that
are identified by planning policy and
practice guidance in relation to air
quality and ammonia is one of those
ammonia is the um one of the most
significant emissions from this sort of
operation and that's what's been modeled
in the OD modeling and it is the impact
of that emission on the immunity of the
local area that forms the reason for
your ref your recommended
refusal right that's clarified it very
well done thank you Council sorry my
second question is it's to do with the
traffic
movements um the Fig fig I I've got in
the headline figure I've got in my from
reading it is that there's an increase
in traffic movements from
528 to
4,385 is that correct I know this has
been challenged by the independent
survey but the our figures are four 528
to
4,385 where'd you get the
4,385 from it's so oh
gosh Braun can you comment on that
rather yeah thank you thank you
councelor so on the basis of the
information that has been s submitted in
the transport assessment and that suffer
County Council have accepted so not
withstanding the concerns raised by
stradbrook and thoron Parish Council and
their own independent assessment so I'm
commenting only on the applicants
assessment which has been accepted by
our consult te
um if you have a look at par 4.3 that
starts the information about the
estimated maximum traffic generation to
be 139 Vehicles which is 278 movements
for each of each cycle which is a 7 week
growing
cycle um and that the peak estimated
vehicle number of 30 hgv movements per
day for two days within that 7we cycle
which is the catching period
okay
so over two months we got an increase of
88 to 278
roughly yeah 278 movements over the swe
growing cycle bearing in mind that the
existing operation is to be ceased and
demolished um so there are three sheds
there that are capable of operation to
to potentially to a lesser degree
because they are older but there is an
existing agricultural operation at this
site there is also the fact that this is
an agricultural site unrestricted for
excuse me other other kinds of operation
um but yes for the 7we growing cycle the
estimate is 278 movements over that
period the peak being 30 per day for two
days in that swe cycle
okay thank you very much I'll do some
sums thank you for that councelor war
boys um right so uh no further questions
sorry madam chairman oh sorry councelor
C yes yeah um do we know how oh sorry
I'll put my video
on do we know how many um birds are on
site at the moment um with those three
sheds that are you to be demolished
because it it does seem like we need to
look at the gain in um animals on the
site um if there's already animals there
and those th those um facilities will be
demolished um that's the first question
the um second question is in the
previous
application it says um the unit has
capacity to house
288 um
Birds
and um the um this one is 188 so um
could could I have some clarification on
that previous application and um the um
the the difference in the um amount of
sheds for
those thank you councelor Casten in
terms of the existing operation it's my
understanding that that ceased fairly
recently so there are no birds on site
I'm sure the agent will correct me if
that's um different from my
understanding in terms of the animal
numbers it's rather dictated by Animal
Welfare standards to do with the space
that they are being permitted um so your
question was the difference
between the this three shed proposal and
sorry sorry the um the plan in history
the application on on um the 606 the the
previous um application dc1
19366 okay thank you yeah so that was
the that was the scoping opinion so that
wasn't a planning application that was
um asking us for what information should
be submitted with a planning application
if a proposal for a unit of up to
288,000 birds were submitted in as it
turns out the proposal is slightly
different from what was scoped it is
slightly lesser in
scale okay thank
you may I just come into this at this
point in time uh apologies um we've just
got some very uh urgent news uh for the
chair um so I'm asking now to take a
break um we need to stop recording and
have a break while we assess that
situation um I apologize for this this
is a matter of emergency um so if we can
just have a break and uh we will resolve
what we need to do if we say a break for
10 minutes at least please and then we
will come back and uh resolve how we
proceed with committee I apologize I
can't give you any more information than
that that is sensitive I will update you
as as I can in 10 minutes time many
thanks if you can all stay uh muted and
without video for the time being thank
you very much and if we can take a break
from recording
Robert
thank you all for um waiting during the
break I'm afraid to say that Council
Guthrie has had to leave the meeting and
as such as governance officer I will
just pass over to the vice chair um who
councel humre who will chair the rest of
the meeting thank you thank you
everybody for your patience and
understanding councelor War boys if
you'd like to just finish off uh your
your points from the questions and then
we'll move on to the public speakers
thank you yeah yeah thank you thank you
chairman uh yes I've just I've done a
little bit of arithmetic and so I I now
work it out as based on the the
projected traffic movements are going to
be in the region of
20065 per anom uh compared to a present
of
528 per
anom
and yes can I confirm that
chair if you're taking that on the basis
of the seven-week growing cycle and
there're being 7.4 in a year so your
calculation of 2065 is is right thank
you very much thank
you thank you for the clarity and the
time you took in in working it out it
makes it a lot clearer for everybody
okay um we finished with questions then
councilor War boys you could take your
hand down please and then we're going to
move on to public speakers so I now ask
the parish council representative for
Thor thoron to speak which is Marian
ravenhall you have three minutes to
address the committee and it will be
timed thank you thank you thank you
chair and thank you members of the
council um can I start by saying the
parish council's opposition to the
proposed development is fear ly
supported by residents in um the
district 329 people signed a petition
which I know has been discarded but
nevertheless it was signed and there
were further 92 objections lodged on the
portal um if I may uh Mr chairman uh
make a few more points the threats to
health from this ventilation system
orders and other emissions of Noise with
over 1 million birds being reared
annually at this
site poses cons significant risk here
especially to the attendees at thoron
Primary School which is equally distant
from this site as is the research center
the increasing traffic from these sheds
will also have an impact on our
community a very negative cumulative
impact Mr chairman on our village and
our updated uh um our updated traffic
survey you've got in front of you we're
con particularly concerned about where
the waste manure and litter and also the
foul water will go to once it's removed
from the site there are no Pavements in
thoron and this is a threat a real
threat to safety it's substantial adults
and children walk on the road in
Thornton and our uh traffic weight
restriction that came into force in 2000
we made had a 24-hour survey and I know
there was a question earlier which I
might answer is 24 hours weight
restriction in Thornton The increased
traffic lends itself to more collisions
and accidents and latest Collision being
on New Year's Eve there was further
collisions in the summer this
application if approved will be for
torned in a very unique position in that
on our western boundary we have
350,000 birds being reared each cycle at
the weathering set plant and if this uh
plant is approved we will have a further
141,000 Birds there reared as well um on
on each cycle which makes thoron doubly
uh prone to um all the things that we've
already he heard order noise and dust
particles the the road infrastructure is
not in keeping with the high volume of
hgvs it's narrow single track roads and
uh this expansion would mean that we
would have further erosion of verges and
flooding there's been flooding again
outside this site at um at the New Year
if this proposal is unacceptable because
the harm it we give is by far outweighs
the uh any Ben benefits Madam uh Mr
chairman sorry may I through this
implore counselors to look again back
the parish councils and it Town Council
and your own planning and environmental
health officers and refuse this
application today thank you m s uh Mr
chairman thank you sorry having a
problem with um actually selecting the
mic on and off there um thank you uh do
we have any questions please for the not
used to this techn technology no I've
got big fat fingers it doesn't
help so councelor melon
please um yes thank you chair just a
quick question on the uh weight
restriction through Thoren um how is
that uh weight restriction um enforced
is there any enforcement um or is it
just monitored by the parish council or
whatever
it's uh chair may I chair may I yes
please yeah uh uh thank you counselor uh
yes it's monitored by the uh by the
parish council we have got our uh our
cameras in toron as well which tells us
what the volumes of um vehicles are
going through the village now um when we
undertook the 24-hour um survey back in
1999 um it was obvious that there was a
problem number of people were very
worried about um walking along the uh
roads there and um it it is but it
certainly has over the last 20 years in
fact almost um has much improved on what
it was we do still get some heavy Goods
Vehicles apart from um agricultural
vehicles of course which are always
permitted thank you are there any more
questions
okay excellent uh thank you for your
time we're now going to move on to um
the I Parish Council representative
which is Richard Berry and again you
have three minutes and uh it will be
timed thank you thank you thank you
chair uh good morning counselors um my
name is Richard Barry and I chair the
planning committee for itown Council um
we've objected to this in previous
applications on this site essentially on
the grounds of the hgv traffic that
it'll
generate uh the case officers report
recommends rejection of the application
on the grounds of odor impact only I am
asking you to consider and give greater
weight to the increased levels of hgv
movements openly acknowledged in the
submission and the impact on I and
surrounding parishes and I have to add
that the members questioning in the
earlier session has reinforced the
necessity for this particularly with
regarding Waste
Management uh I'd like to submit that
the case officers report relies too
heavily on what we would consider to be
under research submissions from the
County Council and the latest
information from stradbrook has not been
fully
considered uh we don't think the case
officer's report does Justice to the
Hard Evidence collected by itown Council
and local
volunteers this includes a formal
traffic survey undertaken from the
council's own resources which firmly
concluded that a traffic restricting
order should be placed along the three
routes to be used by hgv traffic from
this
development there is photographic
evidence of HG V Vehicles frequently
mounting the Pavements an abundant
personal testimony including from the
vica I might add uh some of the
photographic evidence was sent to
councilors yesterday and the case
officers report that describes the
evidence as exp experiential that's a
new term on me uh we we do find a touch
dismissive um the re the report also
states that the road network is not
operating at full capacity but this does
not take account of the well documented
pinch points in eye and the fact that
most of the roots where homes are very
close to the to to to the vehicle
movements themselves with more than 100
affected um no site inspection or Fair
assessment of our evidence could
conclude that the impact on pedestrian
and Resident amenity and safety would be
anything other than severe indeed it is
already highly dangerous so to conclude
I am asking counselors to consider hgv
traffic growth to be added to the
reasoning for refusing this
application uh largely for reasons that
Council Guthrie mentioned uh in in her
opening submission in the possibility of
of an appeal and should councilors
decide to uh accept the officer
recommendation in the report I am asking
for hgv matters to be included in your
reasoning for rejecting thank you chair
thank you and very good timing actually
um we need to be cautious though don't
we that the bad driving of others in the
area should not be used to imply that
uses of the new area will be as bad so
we need to be careful on that it's it's
it's not a science is all I'm saying
okay good okay uh do you have any
questions please for Mr
Barry no brilliant okay well thank you
for your sign thank you chair okay we're
now gonna move to the agent which is Mr
Johnny Rankin um Mr Rankin you have
again three minutes to address the
committee and it will be
timed good morning can everybody hear me
okay yes thank you excellent well good
morning members of the planning
committee as per the officer
presentation this application has been
reduced in scale from the originally
submitted for sheds down to three this
is in reaction to consult te comments
and concerns raised by proximate
parishes and
residents it is worth reiterating that
there are three sheds on the site and
these OD stock sheds are proposed to be
replaced by the purpose new ones to
Modern standards best practice Animal
Welfare standards and efficient
pollution
controls the applicant intends to supply
the crown chicken processing planted ey
and the sheds will be built by a local
company C Davidson who have written in
support once operational The Sheds would
employ a full-time manager support the
local economy as per slide six of the
planning officer's presentation
utilizing the regional poultry network
of feed washing bedding and gas
suppliers
the planning statement demonstrated
acceptability against both national and
local planning policies and concluded
the benefits of the application
significantly outweighed any localized
impacts the environmental statement
similar identified no significant
effects arising from The Proposal these
conclusions are reflected in the fact
that there are no statutory planning
objections from Consul tees much has
been made of the vehicular movements
associated with the proposal the peak
vehicular flow will be 15 vehicles on
one day but only on two days in every
sweek cycle average out there are just
three vehicular movements per day the
acceptability of the resulting traffic
is reinforced by the fact that County
highways have not objected to the
proposal the environment agency
maintained objection on permitting
not planning grounds even though
permitting is subject to separate cover
the reason for refusal within the
office's report seeks to protect the
immunity of units on the southern edge
of the
kovan facility the reason for refusal is
flawed the kant's units in question are
large animal Testing Laboratories and by
necessity sealed as opposed to a
workplace where staff would have windows
open and spend time Outdoors requiring a
higher level of protection the predicted
odor levels are acceptable on this basis
considerable effort has been made to
have this point acknowledged by the
environment agency and planning officers
these efforts have been
ignored accordingly the application
provides a good opportunity for the
applicant to modernize existing poultry
sheds meet Regional and National demand
for chicken support local and Regional
employment there is no valid planning
reason for refusal and I would ask
members to support this
application thank you Mr Rankin um are
there any questions for Mr Rankin
please okay councelor Stringer
please yeah thank you chair uh Mr
ranking you you said that this would be
servicing the crown chicken processing
plant the is that the one in I or the
one in kenning
Hall
so to be clear this is a a planning
application stage it's not uh until such
time as as planning permission is
achieved that any contract would be
firmed it's at the applicant's
discretion who they would go into
contract with the intention is to go
into contract with the the crown
processing plant at I but in the absence
of a planning permission obviously that
isn't firmed but that is the
intention thank thank you are there any
other questions yeah can I can I just
come back Could you actually state where
that is for the for the
committee where where what
is ground processing plant what the one
that is at I that been discussed at
length well no I don't believe it is the
one that's been discussed at length but
that's what there are two processing
plants in
I and I think the members think it's
going to one and you're stating another
one
uh to the best of my knowledge there is
only one Crown chicken processing
planted eye cranck Crown Chicken if I
can jump in I think sematics to be
honestly the fact is it's going to ey um
in relation to this planning application
so councelor Stringer it's going to
I I'm really sorry chair there is a
fundamental difference there is a there
is a processing plant in the center of I
and there is also on one on I Airfield
and I was just trying to work out which
one it was I Airfield kenning right then
it's cranswick not Crown right okay it's
cranswick plant okay that's helpful crwi
Crown Chicken is is one of the
same
okay yeah we're not going to get into
debate um you've had your answer
answered or your question answered um
are there any other
questions I've got one question fact a
point as well um in relation to what you
said about it only affecting these
Southern buildings uh to the north of
the site in fact of Oda Oda doesn't stop
it's not a wall it continues and as it
says in the environmental agency report
it does actually say that actually
affects the offices and the sites and of
course those people go into the open air
so that's just a point on that councelor
war boys
please quick quick point of clarity
there you're quite right OD does not
stop but it of course depletes and there
is Council War boys thank you uh thank
you counc chairman uh yes Mr Rankin
sorry to be pressurizing you this a bit
but uh according to your estimates now
there are
1,095 vehicle movements per anom based
on an average of three per
day uh my question is how do you explain
that there's a huge difference between
your estimate of the vehicle numbers and
uh the uh the council's figures which is
265 vehicle movements per are you using
big vehicles or uh no no that's you've
misread that uh we report vehicles and
then you times that by two for vehicular
movements so that the vehicles tally
with that
figure so there are in fact
2,000 uh additional vehicle movements a
year yeah vehicular movements so you're
counting to the site and then leaving
the site you're doubling up the figure
that was confirmed by the planning
officer Miss Curtis
lovely thank you thank you for clearing
that up for me no
problem are there any other
questions CLE boys you can take your
hand down that'd be great
please okay Mr Rankin thank you very
much thank you okay we're now going to
move on to the ward member which is
councelor Stringer councelor Stringer
please uh thank you chair and thank you
for the ability to speak on this
application uh there are a number of
challenges that face farms uh trying to
diversify and and meet the needs of a of
a modern population um um but equally it
it it becomes a real stress to diversify
uh or to expand when when you have an
existing Community uh that has
constraints uh and I have to say this
particular planning application has
caused the most amount of emails and
phone calls of any I've ever had in 18
years it is quite remarkable and I think
it is because of the constraints of this
particular site I have every sympathy
with a farmer trying to get on
economically and deliver food uh for the
population of our country but the issues
come when you're in a particular
location that becomes unsustainable for
the amount of expansion proposed and I
think this is precisely what we have
here I completely get the idea of the
County Council not claim ing that road
impacts from this will be quote severe
severe has got if you look it up has a
number of definitions uh especially for
highways and often severe in highways
terms means people are going to
definitely get killed um that is not the
case probably here having said that
Lorry drivers of which there is a
considerable raise in the amount of hgv
movements with this proposal the
shortest route to the sites for for
waste disposal for food coming in and
the processing of the the animals
concerned will inevitably put pressure
on pinch points in conservation areas
with high levels of of listed
buildings unless the 24hour hgv
exclusions in surrounding Villages are
breached that's one of the fears from
some of the local Villages that the hgv
Bands Will just get breached which they
are regularly or that they revert to
agricultural vehicles to move this stuff
in smaller uh uh weight but more in
number and of course we don't have a
root plan for for any of this the root
plan you got gave the Strategic map is
actually including some Roots into I to
service existing factories if those
factories weren't there it would it's
not a through route they're saying
suggesting in I CU if you were going to
service the I Airfield cranswick chicken
unit from here from this site without
going through a lorry restricted route
you would probably end up going through
debam or you'd end up going through
stradbroke which is why stradbroke are
getting really interested in planning
applications that are this side of the
a140 this is why it's creating such a
huge amount of public concern so I from
from my point of view we have a clear
conflict here between
a large expansion of agricultural
enterprise next door to an Immunology
testing PL so they don't seem like good
neighbors and that's your reason for
refusal at the moment but equally I
think that cumulative impact of Highway
movements that we haven't actually been
mapped out as to where it's actually
going to go I think that cumulative
impact does become severe because not in
Highway terms the mppf is clear about
what severe can cover it can cover
social economic and environmental and
actually I think the cumulative impact
of the increase in traffic should be
another reason for refusal in this
instance chair and I thank you for the
ability to
speak councelor Stringer thank you very
much do we have any questions for
councelor Stringer
please okay there are no questions oh
we're going to move on to debate um and
I'll open this item Up For Debate if you
wish to make a proposal after we've gone
through the first round of debate please
use the hands up function so the first
round will be done via the uh Alpha
bacal method but before I start um Braun
you have a
point Thank You chair would you like me
to just come back on some of the
questions that were earlier on I have
some answers now I think that'd be
useful it' be useful for debate and
actually might answer a lot of the
questions that would be raised within
that debate so please carry on okay
thank you so to confirm that the
existing operation has capacity for
40,000
Birds and the proposal has capacity
which is limited by permitting to
141,000
birds that the
operation could reasonably meet 2% of CR
processing
capacity they process 122 tons a day
about a million Birds a week at least
that's their capacity obviously
fluctuates in terms of
waste the enduser operates facilities at
I the energy from waste plant which is
there um fford and elely uh although
fford is the likely end user and I
should also point out um because we have
councilor mayor um substituting that
there was a letter from um CE Davidson
in support of the development which I
think most members did receive but
councilor mayor may not have seen
because it's gone to councelor
G um if you want me to comment on the
severe impact test in terms of Highways
I can do that if that comes out in
debate so please just let me know yeah
we do thank you that that's really
informative thank you okay we're going
to start then with councelor Casten
please
thank you very much Mr chairman
um so this site we're looking at a um a
large scale intensive um chicken
fattening unit we um I looking at the
old sheds that the um that the company
has it looks like they've got every last
bit of um value out of those sheds
there's there's very little um left life
left in those sheds the um we we need
these intensive chicken units it's part
of a supply line the um the chickens
don't travel very far to slaughter which
to me is a really
important aspect of the welfare of these
birds the um there's a lot of things
that I um I don't agree with from the um
Parish council's point of view that the
ammonia will affect people at that
distance but there will be an amount of
um smell ammonia and um also it will
generate flies there's no doubt about it
and having the plinth Medical Center so
close for me that is um that's actually
quite serious that whether they would be
able that would fect their business we
want to in mid suffk we want to help
businesses we want to improve the
economy but we don't want to um improve
anyone's business at the detriment of
another person's business so that's
quite an important key part for me I'm
less worried about hgv travel um and
those side of things for me it's this
how that site would affect the plinth
medical um whe they'd open a door and a
whole load of flies would get in um it's
okay having you can have sealed windows
and sealed doors but people still need
to get in and out and flies do have a
habit of getting in doors within a few
seconds of you opening them so um I I'm
really interested to listen to the
debate on this one but um what I will
say is um in here it it some of the
objections to the um way these animals
will be produced and I think what we've
got to um look at there is
um2 per kilogram for a whole chicken in
the supermarket these Farmers aren't
making a huge amount of money on the
small sheds it's very hard for them to
make a living out of this so um these
these large scale sheds are um okay
they're not they're not the Romantic
small um chicken sheds from Days Gone By
but they are the future and they are a
way to deliver that food to people that
are that are more than happy to buy it
so um yeah I'll um that that's it for
the moment and I'll I'll listen to the
um debate thank you very much thank you
uh councelor melon
please um thank you chair
[Music]
um yeah the I can understand the the
we've got a away everything in the
balance here there's there's clearly an
economic benefit of of having this
development um it's part of a growing
industry um in this part of the world
and um although these are not the sort
of chickens that I would be eating um I
have certainly ethical concerns about
the means of production but I understand
that that is what people want to buy and
um that's the way the industry operates
I mean I used to work on on one of these
sort of plants um for gressing and food
so the there they're common in this part
of the world
um I'm interested just to note that
covans don't seem to have objected
directly I couldn't find anything in the
in the papers that indicated that um so
I mean I think the issue for me is is
the transport um I'm very well aware of
the problems in I I go into I regularly
and there are pinch points there and um
you know is a dangerous place to walk
around at times um particularly on the
corner with the bank there um so those
are real concerns for me and I
understand that it doesn't quite meet up
to the level of a severe
impact um but to me it's still um
considerable um yes I mean the the the
uh the odor issue is is sort of a
convenient um sort of Peg to hang hang a
refusal on um but that's where I am at
the moment and I'll I'll leave it to
hear hear more debate thank you
chair
thank you uh councelor mayor
please thank you chair
um really for I'm in danger of repeating
what's already been said um for me the
traffic issues undoubtedly the if this
plant were built the increases would be
significant but from a planning
perspective our professional advice said
they are not severe so I personally do
not see how we can refuse on the basis
of increased
traffic however we do have a very firm
steer that the impact of the sheds uh
would be considerable in terms of the
odor to the research center just nearby
and I also hear the Paris council's
points about the primary school being on
um the east side of the village whilst
probably not in the High um
odor concentrations um it would still
impact them so for
me our offices have recommended um
refusal and we have firm grounds to
refuse on the basis of the impact on the
neighbors due to the odor and and I'm
happy to refuse on that basis but I
don't think we can refuse on the basis
of the traffic being
severe good point um thank you councelor
Norris
please thank you Mr chairman uh I also
have some serious concerns regarding
this
application uh just heard from councilor
mayor your position regarding the
increase in traffic as opposed to the
advice that we're being given by uh the
highways uh Department um again would
the
anticipated increase in the number of
birds being processed on the site the
capacity which was quoted as 40,000
birds for the existing or previous op
operation U versus what is predicted for
the number of 141,000 on site um which
would be the outcome of this
application to me that must be a fact in
the increase on the odor noise and dust
particles that would be produced and
would impact on the
surroundings um the primary score we've
heard is not that far away um I've got
serious reservations regarding the
traffic nonetheless the increase in the
movement from the calculated 265
vehicles from what I understood was a
sorry
528 per anom currently again must must
have an impa impact a serious impact not
withstanding what highways say and what
classification they put upon it
technically um so I am not inclined to
support this application I must admit
but I will listen to the rest of the
debate thank you thank you uh councelor
War boys
please
uh thank you chair um yeah I I think
Council Stringer as as the W member I
think he was very clear about the sort
of economic advantages of the
development and normally I would be
supporting
um an improvement in facilities du into
more modern chicken houses and that
would improve welfare of the birds
um
however I I I agree completely with the
case offices recommendation on the
grounds of uh air pollution in
particular as the site is adjacent to
the research facility and as Council
Caston points out people have got to go
in and out of these
buildings
um on the issue of traffic um
as the chair pointed out this isn't a
science um we've got some
objective um information and some
subjective
information objectively there's four
times the amount of
traffic
um and yet the the the U suffk County
Council have said in their statement
there's no evidence suggests that
allowing additional
hgvs
uh to use this part of the road Network
would be a highway safety problem um I'm
familiar with these roads uh I I agree
completely with Mr Berry's from my town
councilor brry from my town council's
comments that the impact of additional
traffic in particular on I would be
would be
significant um and it would add the
accumulative effect would be would add
to the risk factor of using and I as a
as a as a
center
um but we've had
um a paper of an
appeal which hinged more as I understand
it on the fact that the um information
regarding traffic movements is is
uh doesn't apply so I think we need
perhaps advice on whether we can
actually add uh refusal addition refusal
on the additional ground sorry of uh the
traffic
movements okay so shall I shall I sum
that up I've wondered about a bit no I
think it's I think it's fairly clear in
all honesty um and I think your points
come across well I think on the highways
part of it um we might think about
adding that but predominantly I think
we're all sort of pushing down the same
route on here on Oda um are you complete
Council War boys yes I am thank you okay
um I'll have my uh my point for debate
if that's okay um look I'm a firm
believer in supporting local businesses
without a shadow of a doubt and
especially those that want to expand and
improve uh the offer from suffk and and
obviously jobs and uh and uh getting
this nation going I also like to support
um local industries that provide food
for the food chain for the nation really
important although again i' I'd rather
go for free range but that's my own
choice um however on this occasion um I
feel unable really to support this um
because of the real concerns of the odor
and the effect on the site just to the
north it's what 200 meters away and as I
said before Oda doesn't stop there's not
a solid line there you know a wall that
prevents it going any further and I get
that it actually dissipates but it's
still there and it still has an effect
there are offices not just sealed units
on that site and people also wander
around that site so there is definitely
an adverse effect and I just can't see
how we could go against the
environmental Agency on this uh page 26
and 27 are full of facts um it's hard to
dispute to be honest with you um and
given the fact that the predominant wind
in the UK or England is souths
southwesterly it goes straight to that
site so I just don't get this um the
highway side of it
yeah we could argue there's a an
increased uh issue there uh increased
traffic definitely there is um whether
there's going to be more accidents who
knows so highways has got some part to
play on this but predominantly for me
it's the odor um so there are my points
really um it's the odor every day um
we'll now move on to the second round of
debate and again this will be done by
the hands up function um and again if
you wish to propose uh bear in mind what
I've just been speaking about the odor
maybe the highways but the odor is the
main reason within the document um if we
have a proposer please propose U but I
will be looking for a second to support
that straight away open to you
guys who's going to start
debate it's normally me but it's not
today so councelor Caston
please thank you very much yeah I think
that was a really useful um debate
actually I think um we've we've sort of
we've covered a lot of the ground but
for me this proximity to the um the the
center to the north is um it's just the
wrong site for this I think it's I
really want to um I really want to
approve this because I think this is
exactly what we need we need to um we
need to give these smaller Farms which I
believe this is a smaller Farm because
they can't they haven't got enough land
to spread the manure on um we've got to
give them a chance of producing huge
amounts of food which um they this this
look looks like it's exactly what
they're trying to do but I just I think
with that um with that sight so close
with that prevailing wind like you
talked about um Mr chairman with that um
the the wind coming from that direction
I think it would have a severe detriment
to this um business and um NE after that
debate I'm um I'm minded to refuse and
um happy to propose
refusal um at this
stage okay thank you and is that a
proposal for refusal on the grounds of
the
odor on the um on the ground yeah on the
grounds of the odor that's for me I'm
I'm quite happy for people to add um to
that a second or to add to that or in
when we discuss it but um for me it's
the odor and the um and and the
environment mental health aspect of
having those um those sheds in that
proximity to the thank you I think it's
clear I do need a second
please okay counselor mayor
please thanks chair I'm happy to second
on that basis or the Oda being the
reason for refusal
um but I would be interested
to hear any other um proposals that that
perhaps expand that I'm I'm still unsure
as to whether we should add traffic I'm
not prepared to propose that we add
traffic um but I would be interested in
what others have to say okay so we do
have a proposer and a second there and
and I guess this is as per the officer's
recommendation uh which I think is
sufficient within the document um we
will move to the second round of debate
so um Council
melon yes thank you chair
[Music]
um yes I I'm I'm in agreement with the
proposer and second I would like to
see um some aspect of the traffic
problem included in this um but I
believe that the officer was was was
prepared to give us some more detail on
that and I'd like to sort of hear what
what she has to say if that's
possible yeah actually I think bring in
um yeah Mr payman G
please thank you uh do you want my video
on I'm never sure if I should be or it
depends depends on you
really I don't have the official
background that's what I'm just
conscious of ab um in terms of the
debate so far um obviously the officer
recommendation is for Oda um if we are
going any further other than that um
there are risks attached to that that we
we feel um you know members have
actually debated uh to a degree we
obviously have the recommendation from
the highways Authority which is not to
uh refuse it essentially on highways
ground they don't feel the impact is
necessarily severe enough for that um so
our options really are to go forward
with the officer recommendation members
may wish to add further reasons to
refusal and they could add uh highways
um the other option is that we do put an
informative on the refusal about
highways so should uh this go to appeal
in respect of odor it it's highlighted
that there maybe wider considerations
the inspector may wish to take into
account um but it will only be an
informative so the choices are
informative or you actually do refuse it
on highways if and I don't know how far
to go here we were to look at uh a way
refusal in terms of Highways my only
suggestion would be that there the
uncertainty of rooting um the
information you have to hand is perhaps
a factor um to that
consideration um you know it's it's that
is insufficient information as an
argument perhaps is something that is uh
a valid Way Forward but I I notice Ian's
just put his his hand up so I don't know
if he's wanting to add anything more
than that to me what I've said sorry
John I didn't mean to inter you sorry Mr
P if I may chairman um sorry John I
didn't Mr pman G I didn't mean to
interrupt you but I just there was a
point I could have made when you
finished but I'll say it now that if if
members vote to refuse and if they if
they vote to refuse as recommended by
officers on the ground of odor I an
informative may be useful if members are
so minded whe whether there is an
informative or not if there is an appeal
we don't know for all that we know there
might not be one but if there is the the
planning inspector will not be bound by
the council's reasons for refusal and is
quite at Liberty to hear residents and
the parish council and others and
neighboring councils if if if he she
thinks it appropriate and and consider
the whole issue and it's not it's not
been unheard of I mean the officers have
given advice in this case it's not been
unheard of in the history of planning
for factors not not mentioned by the
council to figure in an inspector's
decision but I thought that point should
just be made here no you're quite right
I and ultimately we have had a here
where they've taken the uh in one sense
the members reason for refusal
disregarded that and actually come up
with a brand new refusal entirely at at
appeal stage uh so that they they do
have that scope
to essentially determine it from scratch
if they wish to um I think I'll leave it
there at this stage chairman if I may I
don't know if there was any further
information from bromin I thought we had
everything uh necessary um but I I will
leave that to you to continue if
necessary thank you yeah thank you I
think we do have enough um so let's go
back to the proposer and the seconder um
do you wish for there to be an
informative note put on reference the
highways concerns or
not um personally I don't really want to
add highways I don't believe there is a
serious highways issue that stops this
um for me it's the odor but um if if
we're going to if members are going to
vote on this and if um other members
feel strongly that should be a
highways um issue attached to it
um yeah we can talk about that okay
councilor
mayor chair I I think by adding um the
informative uh caveat uh that would
better reflect the discussion of the uh
committee today so I would support the
adding of an informative to the proposal
but I don't support report refusing on
the grounds of Transport yeah okay
that's nice and clear thank you we'll
continue with the debate does anybody
else wish to come into the
debate uh councilor melon
please yes I think it's just really just
to Echo the the the the position that
councilor May's taking um we don't want
it as as a reason for refusal but it's
useful to have that um uh that transport
issue just sort of um demarcated as well
anybody else
please coun
Norris yes thank you Mr chairman uh I
Echo uh councelor melon's thoughts on
that I we've heard so much about the
increase in traffic movements and the
fact there probably something like
around four times the current
movements I I think it is still too my
too much of an issue to just drop
completely actually I think as an
informative it ought to be included
thank
you thank you anybody else Council War
boys
please yes I think after Council mayor
and Council Norris's and Council Mel
comments can we just clarify um The
Proposal then how we proposing to
to um support the uh the recommendation
with the
added advisory note about traffic
movements okay so at the moment the
proposal is that um we go along with the
recommendation laid down in the papers
which is based on odor and odor Alone um
but I think what I'm picking up from
everybody here is that we want an
informative statement um that expresses
the concerns we've got over the highways
specific speically the insufficient
information on routing and a potential
harm on immunity within settlements
close by and I think that would be
sufficient if you're all in agreement
I'll go back to the uh
proposer
yes yes I I'm really happy with that
good that's excellent um so I'm sure
that will be added Mr pman G can you
confirm that's going to be added please
for the proposal yes I can do that so we
have an informative the U The Proposal
as
recommended thank you um I think that's
everybody can you just lower your hands
please if you're not wanting to
speak Mr pres um I see you still got
okay thank you okay um so therefore I
think we pretty much finished debate I
can see no more hands up so we're now
going to move to the vote so um I'll ask
the chief planning officer area planning
manager to summarize the proposal on the
table before we go to a
vote thank you sorry I wasn't dising
that uh right uh in terms of the
recommendation so I'll just go back to
the recommendation so the recommendation
is the application is refused um and
they are laid out in your papers on page
uh 29 and we would add an informative
note to that refusal and that
informative note will Express that we
consider there's insufficient
information of routing potential harm on
amenity within uh the settlements nearby
uh due to the traffic created if that's
satisfactory uh
chairman yeah I believe it is and uh
proposer agree
please agreed thank you
second yeah happy thank you thank you
okay excellent so I'll now ask the
governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote
please
thank you chair I'm just adding in the
final piece of wording there and I will
start the vote momentarily so if members
could please go to the modern. goov app
and go to the voting tab by pressing the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
and then um choosing attendance voting I
will be with you in just one moment
because my system appears to have frozen
so um if you bear with me one
moment
right let's see if
that's not quite updated yet apologies
for this chair it's because we have to
add the um have to add the new wording
in manually it um seems to be taking
just a moment to
update right if I just close
that
right I think it's there sorry about
that chair so I will now open the vote
so you the bar for the vote will turn
light blue if you click on that you will
then be able to go in and vote on the um
proposal
um sorry chair councelor melon here I'm
struggling to access the vote okay um if
we can't get on it Robert if you could
please walking through it if that
doesn't work then we'll just take your
uh your verbal vote yep that's fine
chair so which bit is not which bit are
you at counselor sorry it's it's just
asking me to log log on again although I
seem to be already logged on I don't
quite understand why yeah councelor
Norris I have the same
issue okay um so what we're do in the
first is if you could just try logging
on again one more last time if it's not
does it come up with an error message
afterwards
um so I have to actually leave it and
then log back in
agains okay
I've just had a message from my
colleague Mandy that it could have just
timed out so apologies counselors on
that
point
okay I'm in now yeah thank you counselor
councelor Norris are
you uh sorry no I'm not yet just no
that's no problem if you if you are
experiencing more difficulties then let
us know and we'll go to we'll do the um
manual
okay so um I to got councelor War boys
are you having any difficulties with the
the voting either councelor yes yes yes
I am having trouble it won't open up
I've um closed it and reopened it
several times now but it doesn't seem to
have updated okay can I recommend CH
that we just take go to the manual part
on this now yes please yeah okay so I
will ask councelor Norris and councelor
War boys who are the two remaining
members for their votes which will be
recorded in the sorry councelor norrris
actually I have just got back in oh okay
thank you councelor so if I go councelor
War boys could I please ask for your
vote which will be recorded in the same
way as all other votes just for clarity
yes I'm I'm voting in in favor of the
proposal thank you counselor that that
it's going to be
rejected thank you very much so I'll
just wait one more moment for councelor
Norris
that's all of us then chair that is so
that is carried by six
votes thank you so um recommendation has
been carried we're now going to take a
short break um I know it's been a long
morning so let's go for 10 minutes
please to refresh yourselves and uh
we'll see you back here where we're
going to discuss uh the land to the
south of Union Road in one house see you
in 10
minutes
thank you members so I'll just conduct a
quick roll call to confirm that all
members have returned after the break so
councelor James carsten present councel
humre present councel melon present
councelor mayor Pres
councelor Norris present councelor
Stringer present councelor War boys
present and the ward member councelor
John
maton I can see you counselor pres there
we are that's great thank you very much
chair we already I'm I'm not able to get
the the agenda up so so that I can
electronically mark my attendance
unfortunately doesn't want to come up
I've talked to Mandy um so just that
that's won't be
in that way that's fine I can add that
in after the meeting if you if that's
fine with yourself so I can put you in
as an
attendance perfect thank you so welcome
back everybody we're now going to look
at DC 20 treble one0 which is the land
to the south of Union Road in one housee
um sto uh suffk um on now ask the case
officer Bron Curtis to introduce the
application to the committee Braun
please thank you chair okay so I'll
start in the same way as before I'll
just share screen so that you can see
the presentation then I I'm afraid I do
have quite a number of verbal updates
for you no
problem
so um verbal acknowledgement of a late
representation received from a local
resident Mr balum with some photographs
of the Christmas Eve flooding event um
that was reviewed at briefing um so it's
just to acknowledge that we have
received that as a late
representation um
also some bits of clarity for the report
apologies I have made a typo in terms of
um provision of affordable housing the
advice we have from our viability
officer is that the scheme can support
21% that's 31
dwellings just as a comparison to the
Hopkins sign which is the adjacent
development and part of the proposed
allocation overall that secured
20% so it's on a par with the Hopkins
site but I have put 25% elsewhere in the
report apologies for that
um the site just to clarify the site is
a strategic site so doesn't attract a
sill payment all of the contributions
are secured through section 106 and
other mitigation can be secured by
condition
um just was asked to confirm the footway
improvements and bus frequency I'll um
I'll show you the footway improvements
on the plans shortly um the bus
frequency information there is a stop um
near the shepher and Dog Pub on the
south side of the site and near Stow
Lodge on the North side northeast side
of the site um with frequency of every
minutes um there is no uh designated
cycle pathway included in the footway
works for this
proposal um although obviously state
roads will be cyclable in in the way
that any other Road will
be
um an update on the jlp the reg 19
consultation closed on the 24th of
December so that's just in post
consultation analysis at the moment
before moving to the next
stage um there was a question from
Council and about the utilities
connection I'm still trying to find that
out Council maths and apologies I'm
hoping I will have that for you during
the course of the meeting I'll let you
have that as soon as I
can
um and I will respond
to the question about the sustainability
officers comments when we get to it I
think if that's okay with you chair yes
to thank you okay thank you right so the
application sorry another point of
clarity this application first came is
in as an Alternatives proposal which
means um the applicant puts forward two
options for
consideration with either of those
Alternatives being capable of being
developed but the committee deciding on
the acceptability of both options during
the course of um consultation processing
one of the options the option including
the care home element has been removed
from The Proposal um for the reason that
the NHS are are advising that they are
unable to service that type of
accommodation so the proposal before you
is for an outline application with only
matters of access to be considered today
as well as the principle of development
all other matters reserved for up to 146
dwellings The Proposal would also
include um sustainable Urban drainage
system with attenuation Basin um public
open space provision and Facilities such
as that this first slide shows you the
location of the site the North Road on
the north side of the site is Union Road
along the west side of the site is
starhouse Lane and the road bordering to
the South is fbra road you can see that
little leg of additional site to the
Southwest that is below ground Works to
serve from the attenuation Pond to the
river for surface water discharge so
it's not above ground works but it is
work so it's development included in the
site um the site itself is in the
countryside um within the Parish of one
house but outside of the main part of
that Village but you can see on the far
right of this Slide the edge of the
settlement of Stone Market and adjacent
to this site between that Ed of settle
of of settlement and this site is the
Hopkins development which is currently
under
construction so a slightly wide of view
here gives you context relative to the
main part of one housee um village and
also the um Chilton part of Stow
Market town and the Stow lodge
area that's a little bit more clarity on
the red line site and you you can see
that there is um areas of the highway
included because there are some Highway
works for the footway
improvements this slide has been
included just to show you where the
Hopkins site
is um it's it's in where that gray arrow
is
pointing and the brown line is the
settlement boundary for Stow Market as
it's currently defined in the existing
development
plan this is an extract from The Stone
Market area action plan um with the site
area together with the Hopkins site
shown hatched or crossed in the bottom
of you of your picture there this is
relevant because the area action plan
action plan identifies this land
together with the Hopkins site land as
having capacity for additional
development throughout the then
anticipated plan period and was to be
subject um of consideration for at the
first review of the area action plan the
first review of the area action plan
hasn't taken place and won't be taking
place because it's been superseded by
the jlp
process which brings us onto this plan
which are the proposed allocations for
the
JP and you can see La
036 on the bottom left of that image
which includes this application site and
the Hopkins site together as as
comprising that that proposed
allocation
so this is an indicative layout plan um
which you can also see alongside the
Hopkins development on the right just to
give an idea of how the development may
be laid out although just to remind you
that layout scale design Landscaping
issues are all reserved at this stage
and will be considered at the reserve
matters or if a subsequent full
application is submitted so all we're
considering at this stage is the
principle of development on the site and
the access Arrangements
so the access Arrangements
include the primary um vehicular access
from Union Road footway Connections on
the south side of Union Road connecting
to the adjacent Hopkins development and
then further towards the high school and
wreck Etc to the East and footway
connections on the south side to the
west linking to starhouse Lane where
there will be a pedestrian drop curb
Crossing to the opposite side of that
road in order to improve accessibility
to public footpath number
24 on the south side of the site there
is proposed to be a pedestrian um
accessible width um access onto fbra
Road and a footway link from that point
to the junction with starhouse Lane
where there will also be a crossing
linking to the footway on the opposite
side which goes towards the
pub
taking you through some photographs here
this is not the position of the proposed
access but this is on Union Road looking
over the site towards the South
eastsh so we're quite close to the
junction of starhouse Lane here I
apologize for the dimness of these
photographs this is now within the site
looking towards the Hopkins development
which you can see in the far background
so we're looking East along Union Road
at the site
then I'm turning round within the site
so now looking
Southeast and South with starhouse Lane
being on the other side of the hedging
on the right of this
picture this is Union Road looking West
uh sorry East towards the Hopkins site
and the
town these are some photographs taken
from um the edge of the site adjacent to
to the Hopkins development so they're
very similar you can see that it's just
an area of open scrubby grass land with
mature um tree and hedge planting to the
boundaries this is taken from the axis
to the Hopkins site uh looking towards
the application site so you can see the
Hopkins sign in the center and you can
see some of the Street
Furniture so we're looking towards
starhouse Lane in this
image this this is the junction one of
Union Road and starhouse Lane which
drops fairly steeply down towards fimber
Road this is then the Junction starhouse
Lane and fimber Road this is looking
from the direction of the pub towards
the
town and you can see the site in the
center of that picture behind the um
Hedges and trees where those two
pedestrians
are and then this again is little
further along Finnell Road looking
toward WS East towards the town you can
see the Hopkins development just in the
background there the site is behind this
um Bank of
vegetation which is in the center and
I'm trying to show you here the change
in level between the site and fimber
road I I realize that's difficult
because of the density of the vegetation
but there is um there is a fairly
significant change in level there it's
it's about 2
m and that graph again so this is fimber
Road
looking uh to the
West that's the end of the slides
so um it this is a this is an
interesting one because um technically
we we find ourselves in this position
between um policy documents we have the
local plan the core strategy and theate
uh the state market area action plan
which are all of some age
um and have been assessed for their
compliance with the mppf varying varying
degrees and we have um The Joint local
plan which is currently being prepared
but is still an emerging document so we
find ourselves having a proposal for
development in the countryside which
doesn't Accord with policies within the
development plan as they currently stand
but mindful of the weight that we afford
to those policies when
taken in the context of the mppf and the
direction of the mppf you'll see that
the conclusion in the report in the
sustainability section is that those um
policies are given limited weight um and
that given the location of the
development relative to Stow Market as
being the primary Center for development
within the mids area um and the
walkability of of certain facilities and
some of the other key aspects and
benefits of that the development will um
generate the conclusion on the policy
basis is that this is a development that
can be
supported and will continue to
contribute to the um land Supply which
members will remember has been um a
cause of significant work over the past
few
years so um there have been some
concerns
locally um about that policy issue um
and
um I'm hoping that I have responded
adequately in the report to explain that
situation in its technical terms there
also been some issues about um flood
risk and um highways impacts
particularly with some concerns about
the flow of traffic movements from the
development and um the condition of
starhouse Lane so it should be noted
that the highways Authority
have um not recommended refusal for the
proposal they're satisfied with the
proposed works there are some
improvements obviously to the existing
um
pedestrian um access facilities as a
result of the development and it should
be noted that because we've got The
Pedestrian access proposed for fimber
Road there is the option to not use
starhouse Lane for pedestrians and
cyclists traveling by traveling through
the site in terms of flood
risk um I should also point out that the
proposal includes um an extensive Suds
system which
has had approval from suff County
Council the local lead local flood
Authority and their requirements are
such that developments
are asked to provide a 10% betterment in
a undeveloped state of a site meaning
that the infiltration runoff rate from a
site as it stands should be improved
through the installation of the
suds um what's happening in this case is
if I show you the layout
plan I can find it I've gone the other
way is an attenuation
pond with a controlled outflow so the
attenuation Pond if I can show you with
my cursor it's it's you may not be able
to see it that clearly because it's
green on green
but is
in that bottom corner of the site with a
controlled outflow to so the below
ground Works being the
outflow into the river
at the overall conclusion for the
proposal is that we can support it and
we're recommending refusal there are a
number of items that we're still um
working to negotiate the final detail of
the section
106 um and there are a number of items
that we are looking to secure through
planning condition to ensure the
acceptability of The
Proposal um and hopefully that you have
enough information in the report to
explain our thinking on that thank you
chair sorry Brun uh just for clarity you
said recommending refusal is that
correct gosh sorry I'm still in Thoren
mode no I'm recommending we Grant
permission conditional permission sorry
I didn't even realize I'd said that no
problem okay thank you Brun um do we
have any questions please for the
officer yeah councelor Stringer please
uh thank you chair I I have two one is
uh the affordable housing mix of 20% uh
can I don't see an explanation for the
discount in the in the papers what is
the extraordinary circumstances here
that doesn't allow us to deliver the up
to
35% uh could I also ask we have an
objection
from one of our own officers a sustained
objection um and that doesn't seem to be
covered off in the in the papers uh and
reading the mppf that certainly seems
that that should be covered off uh so
could I have an it could have an answer
to those twoo thank
you thank you councelor Stringer um so
on the affordable housing the um
applicant has put forward a viability
argument that has been put to our
viability advisor um Aspen veres who
have done the viability assessment for
the jlp work and the conclusion is that
the site cannot afford to support uh 35%
affordables but similar to the Hopkins
site it can achieved 21% Hopkins has
achieved 20% this site achieved 211%
which will equate to 31
dwellings um in the 146 um and there are
various reasons to do with um the
abnormal costs of development of the
site that have affected the overall
viability in terms of the officer
objection can you just confirm that that
is the sustainability
officer yes sorry it's the only
objection there yes yeah thank you I
apologize that is my um that's my poor
report writing skills probably what I
wanted to reflect in the report was the
progression of the consultation we
originally had an objection from that
officer but um subsequent to that there
was
discussions directly with the applicant
about what was um what was capable of
being included and achieved on the
development and what was reasonable and
the officer has come back saying that
they are satisfied with that being
secured by those measures being secured
by condition which is in your
recommendation that includes a scheme of
um Energy Efficiency including electric
electric vehicle charging points for a
number of the properties so as far as I
am aware that officer is
satisfied and I'm apologized for not
making that
clear okay uh we'll move on to councilor
War boys please and we might come back
to the affordable housing allocation
shortly uh yes it's just uh a point of
clarity about drainage
[Music]
um is it correct that the drainage
scheme would involve uh water being
um going into the rattlesden
river yeah yes that's right yeah which
and um there's been significant flooding
along there recently has that um been
taken into
account yes so the if I show you I have
actually got a constraints map for this
I'll show you the flood
planes the area around the rat sorry my
presentation is not keeping up
with the area around the rat is flood
plane uh the latest event significant
event was the Christmas Eve event and
there was um flooding of that area which
one would expect it being flood plane
it's doing its job The
Proposal includes an attenuation Basin
which will hold surface water runoff
with an infiltration there we go with um
with um an outflow a controlled outflow
which means that it will literally
control the flow of that held surface
water to the river so as to control the
impact on flood risk and that's been um
through County as need local flood
Authority who are satis it did go
backwards and forwards a tiny bit to get
a bit more information from the
engineers but they are satisfied that it
will work and it will meet their
objectives of improving the overall um
capacity of the site so what we will in
in effect have is an improved situation
from an undeveloped
site okay thank
you and now we'll move on to counselor
Matthew please
thank you chair yeah I
um I just wanted to firstly confirm that
the the footwe the the south end of the
site is is is level access not
steps yes as far as I'm aware it will be
accessible in the in the qualities act
meaning of the term accessible regarding
the sustainability officers report
however I can't see in the papers where
he's he's with withdrawn his
objections and I can tell members that
he is available to be called on if they
wish to hear from him no I don't think
we will um we'll just stick with what
we've
got I apologize I believe the um
agreement to the negotiations on that
point was conducted by email rather than
coming in a formal consultation so you
may not have had that full email trail
of um
of Peter being satisfied I was hoping
I'd kind of summarized it in the report
to say that he's now satisfied subject
condition but it is subject to the
condition that you've got in your
recommendation thank you uh councelor
melon
please uh yeah thank you Mr chairman
just uh a quick question on
connectivity um obviously I realized
that the the layout we have is is is
indicative um of an outline application
but if you were to go from so the
southern end of the site and want to go
into town a straight line would take you
through the Hopkins estate can we can
the office just just sort of say is
there any scope for sort of walk through
or cycle through connectivity there um
or are they sort of too distinct and
separate developments which which which
are not
connected they aren't proposed to be
connected and there are some reasons for
that including the presence of a badger
set um and various other other reasons
but um there there is the potential for
connectivity from fimber Road up to
Union Road through this development
through its through its estate roads
which would be almost as directors the
sort of thing that you're proposing just
a little more of a
corner
okay thank you
chair chairman may I come in at that
point just a
moment yes please do sorry having a
problem with the microphone okay um
bomman sorry to just uh dispute what you
just said but I apologies now you just
put this uh screenshot on
the shared um there are there's there's
a couple of arrows I'm just I wasn't
aware of before there's an orange one
next to the uh open space area in the
middle of the um the uh the indicative
plan there is an orange uh double arrow
to the right hand side could you just
put your cursor over it just to just
confirm them we're talking about the
same
thing is that a connection through in
terms of yes but not with a surface
roadway which I thought was
if I've misunderstood the point about
cycle connectivity I mean you could so
you can walk through it but it won't be
cycle my apologies thank you I wasn't
quite clear that that's that's so there
is a a degree of connectivity but it
won't be for cycle or uh vehicular yeah
thank you very much sorry sorry to to
interrupt I just just a psychic clarity
thank you that was a good point uh
councelor matthewson please yes um my
other question looking at the indicative
layout I mean the seem to me even AAR
for some semi- detached and so on there
don't seem to me to be 100 anything like
146 properties shown so I just wondered
um how very indicative that that must be
um unless you've officers actually
counted them or something um is it a
realistic is it a realistic
indicative it's indicative in terms of
the general Arrangement but because
we're not dealing with layout or scale
um at this stage it it doesn't have to
include precise numbers or precise
locations so it's just giving an idea of
how the development could be
arranged okay I guess I should I should
then ask what the um what the the net
density
is members if general information of
members yeah I po that in the report
there's a lot of green there's a lot of
Green Space necessary on this site for
various
reasons and um so the net available land
is not tremendously large if I can come
in on that point I don't think it would
be appropriate really to look at the net
uh density in this case because layout
and the size of dwellings and so on are
not part of the proposal before us and
therefore uh the indicative plan may
have a net um arrangement of density
that is not to say that is what would
come forward in terms of the reserve
matters so my suggestion would be that
we would stick to the overall growth uh
uh density which is in your page one of
of this particular report which is on
page uh
185 which I think it says I think just
to come back if I may chair the problem
with that really is is that the um you
know various conso tees in terms of the
the need for for play space and the need
for the badger set and the need for the
sustainability all these things AR need
we we need to know at this stage they
are available councilor mat have to jump
in I think Mr payment G gave a good
enough explanation and again this is
outline it's not reserved matters uh so
we'll move on please Council
melon um thank you chair sorry just to
follow up on my previous Point um uh
just to ask the officer or or or or um
Mr payman G is there any scope for um
by way of conditions um upgrading the
connectivity in terms of walking and
cycling into the Hopkins
um
development do you want me to answer
that or bman are you happy to answer
that I'm
either okay um so this is this an
outline application that access is
included which means those uh three
forgive me if I'm wrong four access
points are part of uh the proposal for
members to consider it would in my uh
opinion be unreasonable to seek further
access points not shown uh on the basis
that first of all you would be dealing
with a third party which may have
repercussions in terms of vom strips uh
but it is not the proposal before
us okay thank you thank you counc mat do
you have a final
question
no I'm just having difficulty finding
where they put the hand down really no
problem so top of your screen just got
leave to the left of that perfect thank
you okay um there are no further
questions so thank you braon we're now
going to move on to the parish council
representative and we're going to speak
to Nikki wilsh I hope I pronounced your
name correctly you've got three minutes
to speak to the committee and this will
be
timed thank you chairman
um as chairman of by Parish Council one
house is a secondary Village and not
suitable for major development this
proposal is wholly within the boundary
of one house consultation on your new
joint plan closed on Christmas Eve and
there is no adopted plan in place to
counteract the existing um area
development plan however in November the
council published their joint plan um
pre-submission document defining one
house of one of 46 Hinterland villages
the new document suggests that the
council have met the required five-year
housing
Supply this new document policy spo4
suggests that over a period of 19
years that mids suffk will require um
1,267 10% of new houses should be
accommodated which would by my math 67
houses a year between 46 V Villages is
about one and a half a year this is
application for 146 dwell ings would
appear to be far in excess that would be
considered reasonable for our our other
Hinterland Villages this area is a
reserve Countryside site under the
previous plan I believe the application
arose as a result of months of the
council not having an adequate five-year
supply of Housing and is speculative
rather than part of a greater considered
development I question the need for this
development especially in light of the
current pandemic and the financial
hardships that the country will face for
many
years detriment the Lo local resident
I'm cutely aware of the detriment of the
local to the local Countryside and the
well-being of local residents that have
been as a result of the continued
development we've heard from
professionals protest against the
non-impact of flooding local roads and
houses with the implementation of modern
drainage but we live with results of
these daily please don't think we're
against development and new housing for
the past 10 years we've worked really
closely with Taylor wimpy on the
development at chilon Fields attending
play soaping meetings and in involved in
the design with the
developers um that are joins our
residents as a respected stakeholder
this plan development has enveloped part
of our Parish with no recompense for the
loss of amenity or income so I urge you
to reject the speculative application on
three grounds it is not needed by the
community or by the council it'll
exasperate the detrimental impact to
local residents and the environment
which outweigh benefits and it doesn't
comply with your own joint plan policy
um
spo4 thank you
chairman thank you very much uh do we
have any questions
please okay there are no questions and
and thank you for your time uh we're now
going to move on to the agent uh which
is Robert Barber to speak and again you
have three minutes which which will be
timed Mr
Barber uh thank you chair and good
afternoon members um the application
you're considering today will secure the
delivery of a site which has been
identified by the council as a
sustainable and suitable location for
Housing Development since 2013 the site
is identified as a part of a reserve
site for housing in the adopted Stone
market area action plan with
approximately 2third of that site
already having been consented and is
currently being built out by Hopkins
homes the emerging joint local plan uh
forms the review of that area action
plan and again the application site has
been identified as a suitable and uh
sustainable location for development the
site is maintain was maintained as a
draft allocation in the recent
pre-submission
consultation while societ is identified
as a reserve site in the area action
plan and a draft allocation in an
emerging plan it is acknowledged that
the site currently sits in Countryside
in planning policy terms however recent
appeal decisions and and planning
decisions of the council have confirmed
that the local development plan policies
which normally restrict development in
such locations are out of date and not
fully consistent with the national
planning policy framework of
2019 accordingly the weight attached to
such policies is reduced and as
confirmed in the officer report the mf's
presumption in favor of sustainable
development particularly paragraph 11 D2
is engaged in this case whilst falling
within the Parish of one house the
development will form a sustainable and
logical extension to the urban area Stow
Market to inform the preparation of the
planning application a public exhibition
and consultation period was held in
November and December of
2019 the master plan submitted in
support of the applic
demonstrates that a high quality
development can come forward and at
Reserve matter stage will deliver up to
146 dwellings at that Reserve matter
stage officers and members will have a
further opportunity to shape and guide
the detail of development in addition to
the high quality development a number of
significant benefits also uh arise uh
we've talked you had mention of the
affordable housing delivery 21% a
significant over-provision of new public
publicly accessible open space including
play facilities new footpath connections
onto finra Road and Union Road drop curb
pedestrian Crossings on fimber road and
starhouse Lane and sign significant
financial contributions towards
improvements of local infrastructure
totaling approximately 2
million a financial contribution to
deliver delivery and implementation of a
travel plan and provision of uh
infrastructure to support electric
vehicle charging points through
throughout the site you'll be aware that
Stow Market sits at the top of the
settlement hierarchy Mr Barber you need
to summarize now you have about 10 okay
sorry thank you uh I would just uh
conclude that there are no technical
objection to this site and I would uh um
commend this application to the members
today thank you thank you very much um
are there any questions please for the
agent yeah councelor Stringer please uh
thank thank you chair sorry to sound
like a stuck record um the the inability
to deliver 35% what what were the uh
outstanding reasons we got we got a
viability assessment so of course
Financial viability is a key plank of
sustainability so if it can't deliver on
all the uh social and economic
requirements it makes it less
sustainable so I'll be interest to see
what were the outstanding circumstances
here as opposed to any other Green Field
site in in mids
okay chair I'm happy to come back on
that um so there were a number of uh uh
elements that uh were uh dealt with
through the viability assessment and and
as your officer has already confirmed
that viability assessment was was uh
reviewed by your own Consultants um
combination of section 106 costs
um if if I may I'll come in actually
I'll get um I'll get Mr pman just to
give the the definitive answer okay
thank you thank you Mr P sorry just to
come in on that I do apologize and and
um ultimately um the let's start with a
policy the the policy that we have is as
midic District Council is of an age um
let's just say that before the mppf uh
but ultimately it is a policy that is up
to
35% and one of the definitions that
allows us to consider up to is the
viability of a scheme now we've gone
through the viability uh of this
particular case um some of that is
confidential information admittedly but
ultimately it has gone to um an
independent assessor I've forgotten the
name and bronwin might be able to help
me with that um but ultimately we have
gone through the exceptional
circumstances that come up with the the
elements of build cost and and so forth
and profit and and all the rest of it to
provide both a level of profit that is
acceptable
uh to the company but equally um the the
the costs that we have to go through one
of those costs is the exceptional
grounds of the fact that we have ecology
issues on this site that have been
broadly mentioned earlier in terms of
badges we also have um a sloping site
and these costs are not actually that
dissimilar to CH leaves to the north uh
where we had to take them into account
with the viability of that scheme as
well as Hopkin homes which is next door
and the viability of that scheme so
actually there is a consistency of uh
build costs that have been explored
throughout that now there is a lot of
detail there I don't want to get into
that here um because I think we would be
here a very long time if we sort of go
through the individual elements that are
all in various spreadsheets I don't if
one we need to add any more to that but
does that sort of shortcut this a little
bit if that helps or is councelor
Stringer needing for more
information no now that that that's
helpful in terms of uh being able to w
it's it's nothing that we can get over
it's the sustainability of the actually
location that creates this being not
able to deliver the maximum amount in
our policy that's that's that's helpful
to me
okay thank you are there any other
question please I just had one other one
about the uh controlled discharge of
water from the site there's two elements
to that uh we were told there was a
baseline given what was that Baseline
based upon because at the moment you've
got a uh a contra old plowed uh field
which is actually holding back
phenomenal amounts of water so was it
based on that baseline or based on the
Baseline of I don't know I I'll be
interested to know what the Baseline was
because if you've got to make it 10%
better than the Baseline to make it 10%
better than it is at the moment is is is
exceptional also you mentioned the
controlled outflow does that control
mean it will not allow the water out
when the river is in flood or does it
just mean it gets to a certain level
then it discharges into the
river Mr Barber oh sorry chair I I
didn't know whether you wanted me or one
of your officers to to um deal with that
um so the the the the the Baseline is
the existing Greenfield runoff rate that
that's the accepted uh current Baseline
position um and that is effectively the
flow from the site as it is uh today and
and we have to better that by
10% uh and and what happens is that the
Basin uh stores the water uh to a point
when it is uh uh uh acceptable for it to
be released uh the the exact mechanism
of that I'm I'm not an engineer but I
believe it's to allow uh when the river
has subsided uh in part to allow that
water to be safely
discharged thank
you are there any other
questions okay Mr Barber thank you very
much thank you okay we now move to the
ward member which is councelor matthus
um to
speak right thank you chair um just
briefly to um look at the policy points
um as you've heard this is this is
currently um still Countryside um in the
St market area action plan that review
for which this was a reserve site has
not actually taken place yet um secondly
the something that hasn't actually been
particularly mentioned is that the the
saap and and the parish um historically
has been very concerned to maintain a
strategic Gap
between the village and the town and
that is eroded somewhat by this by this
development and it's also
unfortunately um set to be eroded by an
extension of the settlement boundary of
the main part of the village that isn't
something that's actually been mentioned
yet but um it's it's proposed allocation
ls01 and um I do draw your attention to
the Environmental Management officer who
is recommending refusal um in the papers
that we have before us and I'm not
unfortunately aware of any um any
withdrawal of that refusal so that is
that is still a problem the there's a
number of particular issues that have
started to come to light and I just
wanted to you know bring my local
perspective to some of those the the
soil of this site is very poor for um
for infiltration of the water hence you
hear that the will be the pipe put in um
that's going into a river which is
flooded very badly Again Last Christmas
Eve what happens is that the flood
barriers are there just a slightly
Upstream of of of this the site dis the
this discharge that's proposed and and
then when that's full it overflows and
when it overflows we then get to a point
where the road roads are closed um and
that is the road from kums
Ford um up to along kums Lane to go to
fimber that way and also the
b1115 road um which is fbra Road also to
go to up to fbra Village but both of
these actually are getting closed closed
to traffic most years now that's the
degree of flooding that we've we've
already got so I'm bound to wonder
whether the um we are allowing enough
additional capacity for climate change
um to
make you know for it to get worse it
would need some pretty big flooding um
you know ponds to catch it and um again
just illustrating the problem with the
um the lack of percolation the site next
door Hopkins um when they were working
starting on the Earthworks and so on the
site I guess a year ago roughly um we
had heavy rain and the fbra road below
this this this site and the Hopkins site
flooded to the point of being closed
again as well so you can see this is
quite some quite some problem
right apart from that the the highways
um say oh well there's no problem um a
long time
ago the there was an appeal decision
regarding these two pieces of land
Hopkins land and this land before us um
called the luck decision and that appeal
refusal uh dismissal um was was because
of the junction of wus Road fimber Road
and Recreation road now that Junction is
no better today than it was a couple of
three decades ago when that dismissal
took place we've not improved it and it
is an accident black spot I don't know
whether it's on the map that was was
provided or not but I do know that
there's been a cyclist knocked off their
bike and put in hospital um just before
Christmas at that Junction so that
Junction is a problem that hasn't been
talked about and that that worries me
considerably then really the the the
final set of points as to why really
this ought to be um refused at the
moment is that we've got 1100 homes
under construction within one kilometer
of this site
already and um 200 that 1100 actually
now occupied give or take some um the
annual monitoring report tells us that
there are
6,063 homes that have got permission
that have not been started on at all and
another 529 under construction so
there's a big question there about the
need to get on with this at the moment
when we've got all that lot underway or
potentially available to be underway as
well so
the
you've heard about the viability so why
why would we want to press ahead with
this site and only get 21% affordables
when we can find other sites in that
6,000 or or or still to come which which
would deliver 35% so that's quite a
problem so looking at those need issues
why do we need need to to have a tilted
balance against the policies and the
problems um then if if however you're
minded to approve then I would like you
to look at mppf 148 and
150 particularly regarding the
orientation of the
properties in order to maximize solar
gain and minimize energy
bills I think there ought to be a
further look at the flood mitigation
before you go ahead and I can't see why
on Earth we would want to connect to the
gas grid when we know that gas is going
out of fashion and is going to be banned
within a couple of years so those are my
points thank you
chair thank you um do we have any
questions for Council matthewson
please I've got a couple um first one is
um data really you talk about the
flooding The increased flooding and the
closure of roads have you got any data
to support the closing of roads are how
many times a year does it happen well I
I've I've said I've said that it has
happened it's it's it seems to be moving
up to a point where I I used to live
quite near to this site um half a mile
Downstream or something and you know so
I was very acutely aware of the of the
when it did
Flood and at that time it was perhaps
every every two or three years and it
seems to now be becoming an annual
occurrence um certainly it flooded a
year ago certainly it flooded this year
vehicles were trapped in the water
because they foolishly tried to go
through it so I I would say we moving to
a point of it being an annual an annual
occurrence okay thank you um and is it
not true that the um the look uh
decision that you spoke about was before
the improvements made to the A14 and
also before the Stow market area action
plan it's certainly before the Stow
market area action plan I don't quite
see how the A14 is helping I mean the
the the issue the issue for that
inspector um was in terms of people
getting into
town um not people trying to get to the
A14 because obviously to get to the A14
even at that time they would have been
able to take Chon way to get to the A14
but it was the issue was getting into
town all right I might um I think I'll
bring in um Mr Pikman G actually just to
give some clarity if you could please on
that and the
relevance yes sorry if I can um the so
the L luck decision was a little while
ago now um and of course an awful lot
has changed um in terms of the makeup of
this particular area um on this side of
Stone Market as well as obviously our
policy basis um the the main point here
though is that since that decision we
have obviously got the ster market area
action plan uh that has this as a
reserve site we have actually had other
development around here now coming
forward but in terms of the link to the
A14 we we also went through um The hly
Interchange improvements and the new
road uh which uh obviously part of that
was to avoid uh traffic going through
the uh St Market Town Center I don't
have all of the details of that but of
course they are part of the various
jigsaw blocks that have kind of
materialized since uh that particular
appeal decision you can give it weight
members are at ability to do that but my
person well my my professional advice
would to give it very limited weight if
it was to become a a further point of
discussion thank you thank you hopefully
that's cleared that um other questions
there are no other
questions
F counselor Stringer sorry I've just
seen your hand up everything's a bit
slow today including myself uh this is
basically actually a question for the
officer that's come out of the
discussion is that is that permissible
um uh because it's very relevant for
myself I I have I I have a huge issue at
the moment with the the outlet of water
as it were the wrong side of a storm
gate when the environment agency who
everyone is signposting is the relevant
person to comment have actually made no
comment I I I feel that to make a
decision based on no comment is is
frankly not good enough from the
environment agency uh and for us to make
a decision including that flooding issue
I think would be incredibly Reckless if
they've made no comment the relevant oh
you can
okay
yeah the Water Resources act from a few
years ago reorganized responsibility for
various flood risk and the EA are not
responsible in this case it is sa County
council's lead local flood Authority so
they've been consulted they have looked
at all the engineering information and
they've accepted it thank you are there
any other questions for councelor
matthewson okay in that case we're going
to move on to debate uh um which will
basically go around again alphabetically
and the second round will be hands up so
starting with councelor Caston
please thank you very much Mr chairman I
don't see a huge amount of reasons for
refusal on this site it seems to me a
sensible place to build houses the
connectivity um yes it would be better
if they were it if the um the
the areas were paved but it's still well
connected to me but I would like to talk
about drainage so um I think there's
quite a lot of um discussion about this
um flooding issue and there will be so
um whether this land is drained or
undrained um problems with flooding
occur when the ground's saturated it's
um it can land can absorb a huge amount
of water until it becomes saturated it's
a a certain maximum it reaches and then
that's when flooding occurs that's when
land drains start to flow and that's
when you get surface runoff um this Suds
um configuration will definitely
mitigate that flood risk it will
definitely mean un less water going into
the rat River um because it will be
controlled it will the uation basis and
we'll hold it back and release it slowly
and I think they'll easily achieve
10% on this doing this in this way um
it's not a issue for me the um the
affordable housing side of this I think
is unfortunate I don't like to see less
than the um the 35% affordable going in
I think the surrounding developments
have set a president for that and um I
I'm sure a lot of thought and
negotiations gone into that so for me
that's something that it is unfortunate
but I I think it's acceptable to me so
um from what I've heard so far I I would
be minded to approve this but I'll
listen to wait proposals we'll wait till
the second round yeah yeah I mean in
debate uh at this stage I'm I would be
my my mindset would be to approve this
but um going forward I'm listen to
debate and I'll um I'll take um other
counselor's opinions into
consideration thank you uh councelor
melon
please uh yeah thank you chair um so
this development if it was approved you
know is is part of a considerable amount
of development going on at this end of
Stow market and
um uh you know clearly is is um is going
to create a a lot of traffic um and you
know the pinch points that we know about
particularly that that horrible Junction
on Recreation Road Corner um can only
become more problematic whichever way
you go into town from from this
development um you you're going to end
up at the same point
there um and and you know we do need to
to sort of bear that in mind um the
flooding issue um yes obviously the the
attenuation Basin is going to help I
would like to see you know all these
houses with rain water storage that
would really uh slow up a lot of uh
water going into the system um and would
reduce the um the demand on on the pipe
system over the longer term as well um
so I don't know that's something we
could condition the the affordable
housing percentage I mean that you know
we're not a party to all those
negotiations but that that definitely
gives it a thumbs down from from my
perspective um we should be doing better
than 20% um if we possibly can um I'm
not convinced that the developers not
going to make money on on that basis but
um those those obviously those
calculations have been made um so I'll
listen to the debate further um I'm sort
of on balance not very happy about this
but we'll hear what others have to say
thank you and just for clarity um you
mentioned uh Recreation Road you're not
sure you're not actually mean in The
Junction between one House Road and
115 no I'm talking about the corner of
you know of the recreation ground where
where all the traffic will will end up
the road okay thank you yeah thank you
okay uh let's move on let's get for
councelor mayor please thanks chair um
on balance I I don't see that we've been
presented with a reason for refusal all
of the um agencies have deemed it to be
um a reasonable development that's
flooding
Etc I do share the ward members concern
about the speed of
development it it's interesting that um
not sure whether ccg or um National
Health England gbly says that the sto
Heath and kum's Ford surgeries can be
expanded yes but when um it's
interesting perhaps not too relevant one
of my residence in badash recently found
wpit surgery to be told she was 91 in
the
queue she made a rather um off the cuff
comment she's 92 years old and was
concerned that she might not live long
enough to get an appointment um but
having said that I I know of no
mechanism to say that we can
approve but not yet so on that basis I'm
I can see no reason to object to this
and and I would um I would support
approval but I I look forward to hearing
what other members have to say thank you
uh councilor Norris
please thank you Mr chairman um I do
have a number of concerns on this
application I understand that the site
has been identified as a visually
important open space which leads to some
environmental um concerns of mine uh the
flooding
potential onto finra Road I know the
area quite well I have been involved in
that in the past um yes an attenuation
Basin has been mentioned with a
controlled outflow but to a certain
extent if it's going into the rat River
then all it's doing is moving the
problem a little bit further down there
must be considerably more runoff as
built form um than on per permeable
ground uh I believe the site to be
outside the existing settlement boundary
and I do take councelor matson's point
about approved applications that are not
yet built out I'm not very impressed
with the potential for affordable
housing on the side I think there's more
opportunity there must be more
opportunity amongst the con considerable
proportion that aren't built out of
these approved applications for a better
allocation of affordable housing so I I
think there must be better sites I think
this ra is rather in the wrong place so
I'll leave it at that but I will listen
to the rest of the debate thank
you thank you uh so we'll move on to
councelor Stringer
please thank you chair yeah I I too have
it's one of those ones that seem to be
jumping the gun this really would have
been helpful uh to await the out come of
the inspection of the joint local plan
where all of the issues that surround
this that we're trying to Grapple with
today are actually forly tested uh by
government inspection uh those that
write the
mppf um so from my point of view I think
this is of just premature uh and just
adding to so we're being asked to
approve something that won't deliver
some of our strategic priorities which
is actually to help house the most
vulnerable so uh and if we can't do that
in our Town
centers uh then Lord help us in trying
to rebuild our economy so I I frankly uh
would would uh would not support this in
its current form for those that wish
that think this is acceptable under the
nppf I would actually draw your
attention to where the
recommendation is upholding uh and and
stating paragraph 148 and 150 of the
mppf uh the mppf calls for radical
reductions in Greenhouse emissions that
needs to be conditioned if you are to
get anywhere near approving this because
not only has the government put that in
the mpf but we have actually declared it
as an emergency ourselves thank you
chair yeah thank you Council Stringer is
that not actually part of Reserve
matters though so it will come up I'm
sure no no no no no no sorry I was
trained in planning over 18 years ago
every training I've ever had has said
never ever rely on something at Reserve
matters that you haven't put in outline
stage okay thank you good point um so uh
councilor War voice
please thank you chair um yes I think Mr
Barber put uh a strong case for
development and talks about a high
quality
delivery um however I've got I've got
some concerns I think two basic ones
uh the first one is that the um the
Heritage team have put forward a very
strongly worded objection to the scheme
on the ground that it impacts the
setting of U
important um historical assets um and it
is this U further third of EX the
existing development which encroaches on
these historical assets it's adjacent to
a special
landscape
area I I think the
other the second point is uh as Council
mayor said it's the speed of
development um this uh the stress on the
infrastructure of an inent
Village uh the need for this housing
certainly hasn't
been
um
clarified uh it doesn't meet certainly
doesn't meet the our Target in terms of
affordable housing
um and we coming back down to the stret
suff wildlife trust has
also um got a holding objection due to
the lack of sufficient ecological
information this is a Greenfield site
it's great to agricultural land um and
we we've seen from the um photographs
that there substantial hedge
rows and the final thing is about the um
drainage system the tentation
basins
um I think that comes back to speed of
development we we're in a we're in a
period of climatic change and things and
it is changing and it is changing
rapidly I think we need to sort of look
at what the impact of the current
development is how that affects surface
water and drainage before further
development which is going to further
stress the
system thank you thank you councelor
warboys I've just checked um through the
recommendations for Council Stringer it
does talk about um resource efficiency
sustainability scheme agreed EV charging
and also
the construction Environmental
Management plan I'd like Mr pman G
perhaps just to clarify what is in
there yes thank you um I was just going
to suggest that obviously we we're
picking up on the the environmental uh
Improvement side of it and obviously we
got to condition uh within your your
papers uh to secure that um but what we
haven't done is actually put a timing
around that and I think um what might be
useful is to clarify and if just to
clarify the timing of this is important
I think I take councelor Andrew sorry
councelor stringer's Point uh uh quite
quite helpfully um it does need to be
considered now in terms of the principle
of whether it is a reserve matter or not
so this is the point that we need to
impose it which is what we as officers
have done but what we need to think
about maybe is the timing of that we
don't want it to be a separate matter we
want it to be embedded in the design
that may come forward uh on this site so
what we should ensure and I would from
my point of view if you allow me chair
to change our recommendation very
slightly on this point which is to say
that this shall be dealt with prior or
concurrent with the first Reserve matter
application so to ensure that it is
ahead of the game in terms of the design
considerations and not a separate point
that has can be dealt with parallel it
it needs to be uh up front so if we
haven't put the timing of it on on your
recommendation we don't often do that
but I think in this case it would be
useful to do that um and and that would
be that would allow us to as officers
when it came to Reser matters um be um
fully engaged on that point uh before we
get into the absolute layout and design
that should well in be part of that same
conversation um that's really all I
wanted to add there I I don't think I
obviously we we've jumped on a few other
things since I I was thinking about that
so I'll let the debate continue but I
see brn's also put a hand up so is are
you wanting to say more than that
bomman chair if I may if it's helpful
for me to come back on a couple of
councilor War boy's concerns there may
have been some confusion with the way
that I've represented consultation
responses in the report which I
apologize suff at Wildlife trust had an
initial objection that has since been
resolved that is summarized in the
consultation section but perhaps I
didn't make that clear enough they are
now satisfied with the information
that's come in and the mitigation
proposals in the recommendation Heritage
have not raised an objection that they
have commented on the degree of harm
which is what they have to do in every
case because there is always an impact
and it is on a spectrum of harm you have
a late paper which draws out a bit more
detail in that for you so that you can
be satisfied that the Heritage officer
has given due regard to the impact on
the historic landscape and the
particular assets that have been named
um she's satisfied that um by granting
permission you won't be failing in your
statutary duty thank
you thank you Braun thank you Mr P um so
Council TR Stringer I think that I think
what he said is right and it's probably
appropriate um your
thoughts yeah thank you chair I just
wanted to say uh appreciate the input
from uh uh from Mr payon G he mentioned
the so we're ahead of the game what I
what I'm suggesting we we should be
doing these conditions is they actually
setting out the rules of the game which
is the mppf paragraph 148 150 and we
have not stated there just to say you
will expect resource efficiency well
that doesn't actually say what you mean
or what it relates to uh We've we've got
some policies in that area we've got a
merging policies in the area but the
government has a national planning
policy statement about that and I think
we should put that in that so it guides
the applicant is to what they're
expected to
deliver I'll allow Mr P to come back few
minutes just to put his head together on
that one um I can come back straight
away chair if You' like um I entirely
agree uh ultimately the nppf is uh the
national planning policy framework and I
have no problem with slightly
reconstructing the condition to say that
the applicant needs to demonstrate its
uh um start again needs to demonstrate
how it has complied with those
paragraphs perfect let's do that then
and you can work on that while we
continue the debate um so we're now down
to my point I suppose in the debate um
I'll answer a few points actually raised
by other councilors that go through my
debate points but the the area of
historical importance I guess um Council
War boys referring to popa's grave just
so people are understand where that is
that's about 200 meters Northeast of the
site and between the site and popa's
Grave there's a line of buildings
already that have been there for a
number of years um so I don't think the
view has been changed in any way and I
don't think knowing ppus grave and
having walked around it and run around
it regularly um I don't see that you can
actually see the estate from porpus Gray
so I don't think it has an adverse
effect on it in my own personal opinion
but it is my own opinion um I welcome uh
this estate in some respects um it's
part of a joint local plan it's been
identified as an area for for
development it naturally links on to the
Hopkins estate that's already there and
I think the benefit of the the small
benefit actually which is actually a
major benefit for most people is the
foot path connection with fimber road
which allows people to walk down it to
get to the pub to get to the lake to get
to the cafe and support local businesses
um that's really important and it
actually links up to really good foot
paths the problem at the moment is that
there is no way of doing that apart from
walking down down starhouse Lane which
is really dangerous or using the public
foot paths which are impassible for the
winter months so I welcome that I think
it's fantas fantastic news um the flood
side of life I agree with um councelor
Casten really that the attenuation pool
will slow down the rate of water that
runs into the rat and that flood plane
Basin that has always flooded actually
um and that will actually because it be
10% better than it is now will reduce
the effect so that's a good thing surely
um and therefore it's um I don't see an
issue with it perhaps possibly to
improve things more we could have rain
water um harvesting systems added as
well maybe that's a thought that we
could go down just to improve it even
more but
um as a
development I think the location is
right uh because it's adjacent to a
current location that's being developed
it's got good access in Stow Market um
it's close to the to the bus station
there's good Pathways and everything
else uh and I just think personally I do
think it's in the right place I don't
think there are many other places in
Stow market now that are as good as this
in in form of connectivity and uh and
that includes sort of access to the
roadways the foot paths and cycle paths
and all sort of buses um I can't see any
planning reason for refusing of this to
be honest with you I think all the
answers have been really answered but uh
we'll continue debate um and as we move
into the second part of debate that
second part of debate will be done by
hands up uh and if you do have a um a
proposal I will be seeking a second
there pretty much immediately before we
continue so let's continue into the
second round of
debate who wants to start it's like an
auction isn't
it okay let's start with councilor mayor
please thanks chair um like you I can't
see any reason planning reason to uh
refuse this
application whilst I've Heard lots of
concerns I don't think any of those can
be translated into a reason for refusal
so
unless other members of the committee
can formulate a reason for refusal based
around their concerns I think we have no
option but to um well I would be I don't
want to propose at the moment because I
want to give those that have concerns a
chance to formulate their own proposal
and that's where I think we should go
now thank you councilor Caston
please yeah I um I agree with councilor
May um I think he's right to say maybe
we'll give the people that are the
councilors that are not too sure on this
a little little bit more time but I'm
quite willing to
propose this um make a proposal um if if
they want to speak now I'd be quite
happy to hear it okay so I'm taking that
as a proposal for the recommendation
that's in front of us but before we do
that full proposal uh I'd just like to
hear from um Mr pman G about the
additional element that we were going to
add so we know what we're actually
proposing thank you uh chairman uh so
I've so in the at the moment we have a
condition within your recommendation
that says resource efficiency and
sustainability scheme to be agreed
including EV charging um I uh would like
to change that if well I'd like to
recommend we change that to a a scheme
for resource efficiency and
sustainability and I should put in
including so we don't want to lose that
including EV
charging
um that demonstrates compliance with the
nppf paragraph 150 and 153 shall be
agreed in writing prior to or concurrent
with the first Reserve matters uh
application does that make sense does
that
satisfy Council
Caston yes I think that's exactly what
we want for that thank you thank you I'm
looking for a second to The Proposal
with the addition
please do you have a second
there okay councelor mayor
please chair whilst I'm happy to Second
The Proposal I repeat my request again
if those who have concerns can they
formulate a counter
proposal no um so it doesn't work like
that so we've got a proposal in a second
there for approval and then we'll
continue the debate and people will
decide by voting as to whether they
agree or not agree so I'll take it to
you are seconding the proposal not at
this time no so we haven't got a second
there do we have a second
there in that case uh I would like to
Second The Proposal as uh detailed
within the document and also with the
addition that Mr pman has just
added we now continue with the debate uh
councilor mayor
sorry chair that was um a legacy hand oh
no problem councelor string
please thank you chair just on a matter
of housekeeping the the mids suffer
officer was recommending you included a
paragraph 148 of the mppf uh as well I'm
happy to take the advice of John pman G
if he says the other paragraphs
Encompass that but our our advice from
our officer was to put in paragraph 148
um I have to say uh I I would like to
speak against the The Proposal if if
that's okay uh I still have serious
reservations about this uh some of it is
its prematurity uh you know there hasn't
been that review technically the joint
local plan is the time for that review
and that has not been through inspection
uh and certainly it's not put put
forward under the uh under the Sheila uh
this site was was flagged up as
delivering the affordable housing that
we required as an authority and now we
see the light of day that it won't and
it's that missing 20 affordable houses
for me seems to be a real deal breaker
here because it's missing them where
they're most needed uh where our economy
will need the biggest boost where our
town centers will need the bigger
support as we build our way out of the
economic and medical stresses that we've
been through and the medical stresses I
also take from the other members as well
in this area the medical provision is is
really not where it should be uh uh so
uh with those reservations I I won't be
voting in favor of the motion uh in its
present State thank you chair thank you
U Mr payman G your thoughts on um
paragraph 148 uh yes sorry I I I feel
that 150 kind of covers 148 and I've
look just looking I'm just checking the
wording now but I I've got no problem
with actually including both but the 150
specifically says new development shall
we plan for whereas 148 talks about the
planning system in a more General
introductory way I would to to avoid
doubt I would be more than happy to
recommend that 148 150 and 153 are the
relevant paragraphs I don't I have SE
there's no real difference in terms of
adding that to uh to for the avoidance
of doubt and and clarity thank
you okay moving on with debate any more
debate
please councilor War boys
um yes I do have serious questions I
don't think the need for housing has
been demonstrated it doesn't actually
meet our affordable housing targets as
as councelor Stringer says where they
are most needed I also think there's a
tension
between um one
house um as aspirations as an intland
Village and to keep its distinct nature
separate from um Stow market and this is
has been identified I'm quoting Penny
uton here our suff County
councilor uh this has been identified as
a visually important open space and
should remain so uh so I think the speed
of development this area is is um
putting under stress on the on the
um on the people's one house and the the
environment so I don't think I can
support the proposal at this
time thank you anybody else wish to
speak may I chairman please yes please
uh can I just point out that um this is
not a special landscape area the uh site
the the road and the land to the south
of the site is but the site itself is
not within that designation uh just we
need to be clear on that legal point
Thank you thank you it's very clear
Council War boys happy with that well
yeah I I do accept that but um it it and
I did stress it was adjacent to um the
landscape area my apologies I didn't
hear you say Jason my apologies I I do
apologize okay cool thank you anybody
else wish to debate this before we move
on
okay so we do have a proposer we do have
a seconder uh for the proposal or
recommendation for approval which is in
front of you uh with the addition that
I'd like uh Mr payment G just to uh read
out so we' fully uh all fully understand
what that addition
is yes so as recommendation with the
exception of one condition to be altered
so it says a scheme uh for resource
efficiency and sustainability including
EV charging
that demonstrates compliance with the
nppf paragraphs 148 150 and 153 shall be
agreeded in writing prior to or
concurrent with the first reserved
matter is that helpful yes thank you
okay I'll now ask the chief planning
officer area planning manager to
summarize the proposal on the T in fact
we've done that pretty much and I'll ask
the governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote
please thank you chair so that should
now be uploaded into modern. goov I will
just start just double check that it's
come through fine and then I will start
the
[Applause]
vote right I believe that's there so if
members could please go to the usual
place on the modern. goov app and go to
the Plus in the top right hand corner
and go on attendance SL voting and
choose the option that you may have to
scroll down which is in light blue on
the page under the item we're looking
at
so we're just waiting on one at the
moment can I just check councelor War
boys are you having any
issues no I think you've just done it so
yes I've done it thank you so chair I
can confirm as you will now be able to
see as well that the motion was lost by
four votes to
three thank you very much so the motion
is lost thank you um so site inspections
there are non to report and therefore
sorry chair sorry said that the motion
was lost hence we will go back into
debate ah sorry okay and chairman if if
I may just without sorry I haven't put
my hand up obviously we the motion has
been lost that means there is no
authority to issue planning permission
to State the obvious but there likewise
there's no authority to do anything else
yet so the committee should consider
what else it wishes what instead it
wishes to
do okay we will go back into debate then
so hands
up C
Str sorry chair uh just grappling with
the it at the moment
um I don't quite know what are that's
better uh right um yes um yeah okay then
in the absence so obviously the motion
has fallen um so we now have got two
options left we either have a motion for
refusing it or a motion to defer looking
for further information or
clarification um so I didn't know whe
whether any members wanted to make any
suggestion in that area because I have
the interest
I don't think it's hugely appropriate
that I propose something in this case
because I have that interest that might
be deemed by others as being you know
not appropriate so I just thought I
would being a sort of a road weary
traveler in these areas I thought I'd
just sketch out the options for the
committee so the committee has the
option for someone to propose either
refusing or deferring for more
information or other clarification thank
you chair I think that's very honest of
you thank you for that and um OB H is
there's no other hands up at the moment
um I'd be more rather than a refusal
more for a deferral um because as I said
before with my my comments I can't find
any planning reason to turn this down
and that we really need to remember you
know there are no real planning reasons
to turn this down this outline planning
permission so bear that in mind as we go
through the debate um and if we are
going to defer what are we deferring for
what information do we require that's
the thing I'd like you to think about
councelor mayor
please thanks chair uh I don't see any
grounds for a deferral
[Music]
um it's I now think it's in the members
of this committee who voted down the
original proposal have now got to stand
up and say why they think this should be
refused and what their planning reasons
are yeah we're not here to express our
personal opinions on you know
things like flooding we have experts or
um professionals who've given us their
advice so I call on the members of this
committee who have voted down the
original proposal to now put a counter
proposal on the table you cannot sit on
your hands we are a planning
committee not here just to dislike
things we're here to to work within the
planning framework we're given so please
a um a proposal from the other side of
the house wise words and um I would
counter that not counter it I would
actually go along with that and and just
state that we do have to have reasons
for this so if you are going to make a
proposal just think of the re the actual
planning reasons for def for uh for
refusal if that's the route you're going
councelor melon
please um thank you chair um obviously
this is a a difficult situation um and
I'm quite happy to put my hand up and
say that I didn't support uh the
previous proposal uh I voted against it
uh and and and there are a number of
reasons for that um now whether these
can be formulated into a a proposal uh
that's acceptable to the planning
officers for refusal I'm not sure um I'm
not sure I feel experienced enough to do
that but the the reasons would be one
the fact that the uh the number of
affordables does not meet our our uh um
aspiration
uh and
secondly it's the fact that this um site
is not currently supported by policy
it's sort
of the development is
anticipating the uh the site being
approved during the jlp and we're and
we're waiting for the JP to be examined
so um there's an issue of sort of uh
prematurity uh and I don't know if
that's enough for uh um a refusal but
those are my my two major grounds for
for for voting against
this okay um that's fine I think I'll
bring Mr pman G in for this this uh this
next point
please uh okay um so policy and
affordable housing um so the policy
position is essentially the same as
Hopkin homes next door that we've
approved as a council um you know we are
in this limbo position of policy I don't
think I can get into that far without
going through excessive amount of detail
but we do have a reserve site here we
have as officers I will say tried to
look at a proactive way of saying right
look this is the position we are in
terms of the nppf and the sustainable
context of of what we have to comply
with with regard to the nppf we also
have the St market area action plan
which does actually um make this far
more confusing because
we I did I sort of wanted to avoid
saying this but you know for the likes
of chilon Le it was actually 200 homes
short um so you know we the
justification is an argument that
lawyers can have for a long time in
terms of housing need if we were to go
down that road if we want more clear
guidance on our current housing position
and our current housing policy for this
site my suggestion to members would be
to defer on that basis so we can ask our
policy team to give you the absolute
upto-date position and take this forward
on that basis perhaps at the same time
in terms of affordable housing this is
compliant with our affordable housing
policy our affordable housing policy is
up to 35% it is not fixed at 35% it's
not like it switchb Council that has
specific tiers that you have to comply
with ours is flexible on the basis of
viability
if however members feel that viability
should be explored a little bit further
that might be a further reason to ask us
to defer to see if there's anything else
we can do to increase the amount of
affordable housing if that is at all
possible but I have no guarantee um that
might be another way forward members
wish to consider but I really don't have
much else to offer at this stage Beyond
those two issues thank you that's most
helpful and um again we've got to be
really clear on why you'd actually
propose refusal really clear um
councilor mayor your hand still you've
got another
question sorry another Point sorry thank
you councilor War
boys yes I oppose this U proposal too I
think
um the the comments have already been
made um about the housing needs and that
this development doesn't can't doesn't
demonstrate that it's actually satisfies
those needs but the other it's the
weight I think attached to the Heritage
and environment team's comments which
were in the agenda
supplement um which have very serious
objections and I think you know they
they argue in terms of retaining this as
an open space it is next door
to um the uh special landscaping area
and I think the impact of uh further
development in this area would actually
compromise that um I take your points
about the burial ground but there are
there are
um uh listed buildings adjacent to it as
well
um the
[Music]
um yeah I I agree that there are there
is expert opinion on the mitigation and
the attenuation basis uh and the
Improvement of 10% which be an
improvement on the actual land itself
[Music]
um but I I still think the that the
point about it the tensions between that
and one house and Stone Market plans and
and housing needs I think is too much
for me just to sort of pass this
proposal for development on this
site thank you I think what might help
um Brun if you come in can you bring
back up the slides that show those areas
that landscape areas that councelor war
boys is talking about please
just to refresh this
all yep just give me a
second hoping they're on the last slide
because that's the way I'm
going I'll just speak about it whilst
I'm trying to find it the SLA
designation basically covers the river
valley the river rat so um the section
of underground works the piping of the
outfall to the rat that's in the SLA the
site itself adjoins and is just to the
north of the SLA in terms of the vios
designation the visually important open
space that's just the Corpus
Graves uh here we go so the special
landscape are is shown in green at the
bottom here and the visually important
open space for the porpus Groves is is
up the top
here so I I if I understand correctly
councelor w please tell me if I'm wrong
it's more a case of referring to the
historic landscape policies and the
value that this space has as an
undeveloped space to the setting and
openness and Rural nature of the
landscape rather than it it in itself
falling with within or affecting a
designation that you might have concerns
over I I think you've put that far
clearer than I have Bron thank you the
if if I may then just draw on what we
did with Hopkins because at this point
we don't have details of scale or design
or layout or Landscaping but those are
all things we can control and they those
are all things that we will be
determining later at the reserve matters
stage so um we can either take
instructions at this point as to what
you want us to look for in terms of
ensuring that we secure um an
appropriate design layout and
Landscaping that seeks to protect a um
sort of that transitional semi- rural
urban
feel um or if you're saying that it's
unacceptable as a whole because it's
better as as an undeveloped space and
that that might be useful to clarify if
we're if we're heading for a deferral
just so that I can negotiate with the
applicant well I I think that we talked
about Bas I think the Baseline is it's
better as an open undeveloped space but
I I do recognize that there may
be it might be possible to landscape it
so the impact is
minimal yeah
so so so where we are at the moment um
we're still looking for a proposal of
some sort the the problem is it's not a
problem actually but if somebody's going
to come up with a proposal for refusal
uh we need to know exactly why and all
areas would be better without houses
across the whole planet wouldn't they
but that's not a reason for turning it
down so you have to come up with a real
reason for it um I'm again out of the
two minded for a defal and for the
following reasons that one we could
actually ask for a defal to go away and
maybe talk about the affordable housing
numbers maybe try and find a few more if
possible if that is possible to better
inform us and secondly we can then
discuss that Landscaping what what can
we do to change that that visual impact
and to make it better that's my my view
at the moment Council Stringer
sorry chair sorry I've sort of put you
all in a little bit of a bind over this
one uh because every vote as counted as
it were and obviously we're a counselor
down anyway at the moment um we uh I
think it's sort
of the the issue of Hopkins homes has
also
raised other concerns because we have
the benefit of what's actually happened
uh uh with the Hopkins home site we we
we said we'd have a resource retention
and we would uh conserve the natural
environment when in fact what we did
allow them to rip out every single tree
bar two uh it was a disgrace what
happened there and that was completely
lawful and we were controlling it and I
think that's that yeah and and in the
Strategic policy of the mppf it says
that we should conserve and enhance the
natural
environment uh and I think it's that
Urban creep I mean over the holiday
period I drove past this site uh with a
family member and I had they hadn't been
past there for two years and frankly
they burst into tears uh because they
remembered it how it was and you can't
you can't go back but it's that absolute
urbanization which I think is creating
that massive concern and it what seems
to be the inability for us to actually
uphold the mppf in conserving what we
wish to conserve and and it's because of
the proximity of that site next door it
just gets more sensitive the the closer
you get to the to the natural
environment uh and that that corner is
you know visually beautiful you know
it's all hedged and treed and it's
glorious I I can't see how in any way
that you know uh sticking a load of
plastic chimneys along that and brick
walls is going to make it look any
better you know against and it's the
harm against the benefit there is a
benefit to housing people but there's
equally a benefit to housing people that
need housing which is why you know for
me the affordability issue kicks in as
well and becomes more pressing in in
what is an urban settlement Stow Market
is an urban settlement and it's a
difficult one because we're technically
building in a hinterland Village this is
in the Parish of one house uh when to
all intense purposes but it'll be be
strategically part of Stow Market but
it's not because that plan is out of
date and that's why the whole
prematurity thing seems to get really
wound up because you can't rely on the
Stow Market air action plan because it
hasn't been reviewed and it's out of dat
and this was only a reserve site in that
so if we hadn't have hit the numbers in
the saap this could have been brought
forward but that never got reviewed so
what we do have is a local plan that
then hasn't been through that formal
inspection for soundness uh which is why
certainly I couldn't support it because
I feel it's unsound
uh you know uh and there's if I can pick
any bones I don't like picking bones
with people we need to get away from the
phrase of there are no planning reasons
to refuse everything about planning is
on balance there are policies that would
suggest this be refused it depends how
you wait
them okay no very good uh I think of
course if you're going to go for refusal
you need to come up with a reason why u
based on exactly what you've said
perhaps but um with detail the Stow
market area action plan I believe um the
reason it wasn't reviewed it's been
we've got the JP that's coming online
and that area has been identified for
development within the
jlp we are where we are uh let's
continue with debate any other points
for
debate do you have anyone who wishes to
propose counc
melan yeah thank you chair I think
to try and sort of draw this to a close
I'm going to have to put a proposal for
deferral um and that the grounds for
that would
be uh the things which have been
mentioned so the fact that the
affordable housing I think we need to
look at it again see if we can get a
better percentage out of the developer
um the landscaping and visual impact uh
whether we can improve that as well and
thirdly um the the health provision um
which C May has mentioned in passing um
we need to see what whether that also
can be um whe we can do more for that as
well um so that's That's the basis on
which I I think we can um try and move
towards a conclusion of the
debate okay else pleas Mr P one
apologies to come in again I didn't
quite catch all three but I I just I
caught the last one because
unfortunately my system went down down
very slightly to the speech so I didn't
quite catch all three of those but I did
catch
Health uh this is sort of coming out of
the blue a little bit here um in terms
of the health provision obviously
various developments in this area the uh
children Lees for example and um others
Hopkin homes have all made a
contribution uh towards uh the local GP
practices um as of now currently none of
them have taken up the money the money
is still sitting there um and has been
for a little while um so ultimately
there's already kind of existing
provision uh in place um so it's to go
down that road further is is going to be
an awkward conversation let's put it
that way in terms of the other two
issues I didn't quite catch could we can
I just capture those again okay sorry um
so the affordable housing I think that's
that um you know understand you know
you've explained the position but I
still think we should be able to where
should Aspire
higher um and then the the issue on the
landscaping and visual impact now I know
that's going to be partly covered when
we get to reserve matters but um I think
we need to look at that at this stage
um in terms of um I'm just trying to get
reasons together for a deferral um
essentially you're saying to me that the
indicative plan that you have presented
showing up to well demonstrating that
146 houses could be achieved
successfully on this site is not
sufficiently detailed and doesn't really
give you sufficient um information to
demonstrate in principle that that that
106 46 can be achieved without landscape
harm well clearly the the layout did not
show the correct number um and is
showing you know an indicative layout
which which um will will have to be
firmed up for the for the for the
reserve matters um but to my mind it
doesn't show anything like
enough
um clearly the the density of that
development is not reflected in what
we've been
shown ultimately we're dealing with the
principle of development here
Landscaping is a reserve matter in terms
of this final detail but in terms of the
general impact on the rural character
the of the area you you know maybe
members are saying they are not
convinced that they have enough
information to hand at this moment in
time to demonstrate
that that a a development of any level
could be integrated into this area
successfully yes I'd agree with that
thank you
John C voice
please C War
Bo sorry talking to
myself um yeah I was just listening to
what Mr pman gz I was going to Second um
councilor melon's proposal to defer I
think that we have insufficient evidence
to to show that development of this site
would um could be mitigated uh could the
ad the adverse effects on the on the
visual environment and possibly the
ecological environment as well I think
there's insufficient information there
uh I think the lack of um the failure to
deliver on our our Target of 35%
affordable housing is significant as
well because I
it it has been set out I think that it
in terms of transport and accessibility
foot pass it it is a useful site but it
it'd be useful more useful if it had
affordable
housing
so so are you seconding I'm I'm
seconding councilor melon's proposal to
defer yes thank you okay we do have a
proposer and we have a second for
deferral we'll come to those reasons
very shortly anybody else want any final
points okay I'll ask the chief planning
officer area planning manager summarize
the proposal on the table uh proposal
made sorry before we go to the
vote right I'm s of rapidly trying to
write down everything here
um
so so essentially let's let's get this
into uh context
um members are minded to defer well
seeking to defer on the basis that
officers will return to the applicant
and discuss if there are any
improvements that can be made to the
level of affordable housing
and in terms of seeking further
information on the an assessment of the
potential
landscape impact of the
proposal and was if I I missed the are
we still having Health as an issue to
add to that or was that not been
included in the end I don't think that
was included councelor melon please yeah
I'm I'm happy to drop the health issue
um having heard heard that explanation
from John pep G thank you so it's on
those two points thank
you everybody happy with the
proposal fantastic okay I'll now ask the
governance officer to conduct an
electronic
vote thank you chair I believe I've
captured everything that Mr pman G um
has as well so I've catch with that in
the vote I'll just just for benefit
share so that Mr pman G is agreed with
what I've put in here because it's very
obviously Mr P G puts it very slightly
differently to myself but just so that
we're on the same
page
um come on
computer yes I don't I don't get to see
what you can see no I apologies this is
one of the new parts of doing electronic
voting so I have got that the
application be deferred for the for
following reasons that information
information submitted to demonstrate
there would be not be a significant
landscape impact on Rural character and
locality to allow principle of 146
dwellings and two yeah so that that
that's that's the landscape part and
then you've got the affordable housing
as well yep and my second part is that
officers investigate and negotiate
whether any any further affordable homes
could be secured is that acceptable as
the I would I would recommend that yes
thank you yep thank you sorry about that
chair just to be clear on that before we
go to the vote because that goes on the
public record um
so with that there this should now um
appear under on the same Parton Dogo
under the I believe Mandy has started it
for me um but this now open in the same
place under the vote that was take that
took place on this it
earlier thank you chair I can confirm
that that vote was carried by six votes
to
one thank you very much uh so the vote's
closed and carried for
deferral so moving on with the agenda
site inspections there are nonone to
report uh therefore thank you for your
attendance there I know it's been a long
one but it's been very important and and
all your points have been really
important and well made so thank you for
your input um the next meeting then uh
will be on Wednesday the 3rd of February
at 9:30 a.m. and they now